Maxim Sagibgareev: какие тут критерии есть успеха у моего, ну,
Maxim Sagibgareev: у намерения этого, да, то есть многофакторно посмотри, какие здесь критерии успеха. Потом пойми, как ты проверишь то, что мы достигли этих критериев успеха. Теперь сделай,
Maxim Sagibgareev: там, составь предварительный план, который тебя приведет к этому.
Maxim Sagibgareev: Вот. Все, подготовь методологию, чтобы следующим шагом я ее запустил.
Maxim Sagibgareev: Вот что -то такое у нас происходит. Не то, чтобы это Рабочий сценарий, но вот он такой. Ну, в смысле, эффективный, самый эффективный из всех.
Игорь А.: Я понял. У меня примерно есть по файлам такой скилл, который я себе сделал. И вот файл, который я тебе присылал последний, он как раз... Ну, то есть любую задачу можно через этот скилл
Игорь А.: прогнать. Он тебе
Maxim Sagibgareev: сделает сразу схему. Это близко к скиллам, да. Да,
Игорь А.: то есть он делает сразу схему, он делает по шаблону и по сути в схеме, как взаимодействуют между собой элементы, ну такой похожий на BPM MAP, но только вот этими квадратиками, горизонтальные,
Игорь А.: вертикальные, расчерченные линии. вот и потом каждый элемент он объясняет раскладывать вот такой у меня есть скилл то есть он по сути там при необходимости например мне нужно какую
Игорь А.: -то задачу понять и вот там достаточно быстро с какого -то приближения он дает результат ну круто то что ты говоришь
Maxim Sagibgareev: попробуй я как бы я не говорю что -то прям работает просто мы смотри мы запускаем всегда пилотный какой -то первый шаг даже без методологии вадим
Игорь А.: там по
Maxim Sagibgareev: своему делать я по себя больше говорю вот а потом я говорю слушай классный пилотный шаг но это случайный просто заход как бы вот нам нужно системно посмотреть в общем и целом и чтобы
Maxim Sagibgareev: не только этот случай применялся а другие случаи тоже работали теперь вот все что сказал дело методологии
Maxim Sagibgareev: вот скоро у нас будет визуализация по данным прям еще немножко и мы добьем любых форматов потом можно докрутить вам скилл какой -то сделать визуализации на графика всяких и методологии
Maxim Sagibgareev: именно работы с данными чтобы показывать их в журналах разных ну там типа мы можем что -то свою статью сделать и она будет не хуже чем например статья в экономисте вот такая вот это
Maxim Sagibgareev: вообще очень
Александр Бондаренко: надо это вообще было бы супер ну
Maxim Sagibgareev: вот мы уже сколько месяц чем -то докручиваем то у нас 10 вас 11 версия то есть мы сделали девятую потом ее уничтожили но я говорю представь что критики всякие там критики собрались
Maxim Sagibgareev: вот и они хотят найти все слабые места и по сути засудить нас вот чтобы ты делал на их месте сделать прямо обнулился что вы сделали с 1 он прям такой типа ну у вас было 50 графиков
Maxim Sagibgareev: вот один можете оставить вот на этих двух данных и все остальное все у вас типа прибор и грудо не удавая подожди давай подумаем смотри мы же с тобой тут не пытаемся что мы потеряли
Maxim Sagibgareev: вадима говорю мы же не понимаем мы не пытаемся новые там электронные тигуры давай ну есть обычные обыватели они хотят что видеть них есть неопределенность они вот открыли журнал хотя
Maxim Sagibgareev: чудо прочитать формирование задачи и критериев успеха тоже важный фактор короче но как я понял
Maxim Sagibgareev: и все и он уже теперь исходя из критики мы как бы вот эта методология критическая он дальше достраивает достраивает аккуратно дотягивает как бы дотягивать чтобы тоже противоречий не
Maxim Sagibgareev: было еще моему параллельно показали смотри есть куча способов как круг круто визуализировать несколько очень старую версию уже делаю как собирать данные как визуализировать их примени
Maxim Sagibgareev: их тоже у себя ну то есть по сути что происходит у нас есть куча регионов если интернационально посмотреть вот например просто даже пройдитесь по вузам да то есть куча регионов разных
Maxim Sagibgareev: узов а как это все совместить вот то есть тебя много локальных таких пазлов а вот именно согласовано адекватно рациональный как бы их сопоставить вот в этом задачу тогда можно проводить
Maxim Sagibgareev: анализ уже международного уровня в данных по продажам или еще что -то бывает разной валюты чё еще там разная методология подсчета принципе адекватная вся критика то что типа не сопоставимы
Maxim Sagibgareev: это все и сопоставим и вот у нас задача сделать сопоставим и потому что моделирование никто никуда не отменял если читаешь каких -то журналах там отсутствие данных тоже тебя не прекращаю
Maxim Sagibgareev: их ничего выкладывать не все равно выкладывают информацию ну
Maxim Sagibgareev: то есть не знаю если у вас есть какие -то мысли поделитесь тоже своими потому что мы хотим как бы консолидировать это что я вам говорю этот тут проблематику которую одну из проблематику
Maxim Sagibgareev: мы решали сейчас но
Вадим Х.: скорее связано с аналитикой данных с аналитикой
Maxim Sagibgareev: и визуализацией, презентацией этих данных.
Александр Бондаренко: Тут видишь,
Maxim Sagibgareev: как будто бы
Игорь А.: это не универсальная история. Почему? Потому что у каждого есть критерий успеха свой. То есть он не... У
Maxim Sagibgareev: кого? У кого каждого? Даже вот
Игорь А.: мы вчетвером сидим, более чем уверен, что если поставить одну задачу, вот просто поставить одну задачу, то у
Maxim Sagibgareev: каждого будет
Игорь А.: свое понимание критерия успеха.
Maxim Sagibgareev: Ну, когда ты ставишь задачу, ты решаешь какую -то проблематику. То есть ты не можешь просто, ну, допустим, если мы с тобой мало деталей дадим, то, конечно, у тебя гибкость будет, как
Maxim Sagibgareev: ты к этому придешь. принципе яичницу можно по всякому вкусно сделать то есть ты можешь по -своему взять вкусно всем нам будет вкусно я сделаю по -своему всем нам будет вкусно саша сделает
Maxim Sagibgareev: вообще там не ищусь у например а скрэмбл какой -нибудь и тоже будет вкусно то есть если там задача накормить то конечно же тут критериев много чем сужаешь задачу тем степеней свободы
Maxim Sagibgareev: меньше становится и мы придем к тому что в ресторане степени свободы нет у тебя каждый повар вот представьте все повара должны готовить одинаковым стандартом должно быть постоянство
Maxim Sagibgareev: и качество тогда вот этот результат должен
Игорь А.: выбирать потребитель данного продукта не только
Maxim Sagibgareev: и не только что потребитель за повара решают что ему готовить сам повар тоже решает
Maxim Sagibgareev: ну какая -то связка короче отец вы согласен что 90 процентов на потребитель ну айфонов же не было потребители бы ну там чем машин не было лошадь бы захотели побыстрее помнишь вот как
Maxim Sagibgareev: с этим быть возражением если все решает потребитель но
Игорь А.: я понимаю да а
Maxim Sagibgareev: мы ему показывал он решает ну хорошо да ну может быть ты прав на финальном шаге
Maxim Sagibgareev: но экспертиза тоже нас
Вадим Х.: создает не потребитель
Maxim Sagibgareev: создает и потребитель создаются потребителем
Игорь А.: потребитель выбирается
Maxim Sagibgareev: как бы он выбирает да то есть внутри как бы тут вопрос именно того что ты ну мы не можем полностью не мы конечно же чем и дело опросили потребителей уважаемые родители какие у вас проблемы
Maxim Sagibgareev: и мы спросили в реке сделал такой вопрос сейчас потом скинул по всем странам например германия там какие проблемы в развитии детей чего у вас там происходит вот мы опросили их, собрали
Maxim Sagibgareev: теперь статистику всю, видим все проблемы, выбрали, мы же делаем выбор какой -то, а потом решаем. Вот такое решение, нам кажется, оно обхватит вот эти проблемы и типа даст результат.
Maxim Sagibgareev: Потом показываю пилотник какой -то группе людей.
Игорь А.: Говорим, что
Maxim Sagibgareev: вы думаете? Вот рекламу вы сейчас тестируете. Что вы думаете про рекламу? Кликнешь, не кликнешь?
Игорь А.: Аудитория такая,
Maxim Sagibgareev: ну, кликну, ну, дальше не кликну. Или
Игорь А.: кликну дальше, да, вот какая -то часть
Maxim Sagibgareev: потом дайдут до оплаты и не оплачу
Игорь А.: да на
Maxim Sagibgareev: самом деле мы смотрим может быть мы говорим купите бриллианты купите бриллианты а говорим антилопам типа в лесу и они как бы ну прикольно блестяшка они такие посмотрели на блестяшку
Maxim Sagibgareev: убежали дальше и убежали
Игорь А.: в китай искусственные
Maxim Sagibgareev: бриллианты покупать да не они вообще пахни на бленд они хотят траву жевать то есть ну я дароделок да да ну вот то есть может быть не тот не то место где мы сейчас тестируемся но мы
Maxim Sagibgareev: одновременно вы же тестирует еще сам процесс работы с данными и аналитику правильно она
Александр Бондаренко: для
Maxim Sagibgareev: нас ну по крайней мере они обе важны наверное но учитывая то что мы никогда не можем заранее знать где мы поймаем рыбу но сетка то нам нужно подход там корабль нужен и вот мы забрали
Maxim Sagibgareev: постоянно вот я вот
Александр Бондаренко: как хотел по сути мы сетку вот эту разрабатываем типа вот может быть сетка с большими гранулами от мелкая рыба проскакивает таки так надо сетку сделать там не знаю чтобы вообще там
Александр Бондаренко: муха не проскользнула ну типа вот эту вот штуку которая конвертирует в
Maxim Sagibgareev: результат
Александр Бондаренко: вот на примере вот мы с этим вебинаром запустили с этим чек -листом и люди прям переходят то есть они уже оставили телефон они уже оставили email и все равно они прутся в мессенджер
Александр Бондаренко: чтобы забрать этот чек -лист и стучаться в личку чтобы его забрать вот 50
Maxim Sagibgareev: процентов на получается даже больше попали
Александр Бондаренко: процентов больше больше ну сейчас уже дальше уже близко сказать 50 изначально было вообще почти все вот сейчас вот 18 человек оставили зарегистрировали
Игорь А.: на
Maxim Sagibgareev: события до
Александр Бондаренко: зарегистрировались на вебинар оставили email и телефон и 10 постучались в мессенджер и попытались забрать чек -лист писались
Maxim Sagibgareev: на телеграм круто круто а telegram как вы назвали main
Игорь А.: experts собака
Maxim Sagibgareev: что там как вы какой собака
Александр Бондаренко: main experts подчеркивание official подчеркивание бот она
Maxim Sagibgareev: супер супер окей не самое важное что вы спросили и что они хотят то есть какой -то опросе губина какие у них основные запросы просто вот самая полная в
Александр Бондаренко: тг
Maxim Sagibgareev: до до получается до первого числа
Игорь А.: это сегодня и завтра можно два закинуть по одному до
Maxim Sagibgareev: аудитория расскажите открытым выпишите нам списком разные люди по -разному там видят круто
Александр Бондаренко: очень крутая идея ну я думаю так надо сегодня выдаст этот чек -лист ну типа если за счет спросит на сошлёмся ну сорян telegram я
Maxim Sagibgareev: бы я бы его есть поменял просто я не хочу это делать я прочитал его он в целом живой то есть он как бы версия какая -то готовая версия а
Александр Бондаренко: мне же пришел
Maxim Sagibgareev: в макс чек -лист мне в макс пришел чек
Игорь А.: -лист пришел
Maxim Sagibgareev: но ты же его не скачаешь
Александр Бондаренко: он то вот он в таком виде как раз ему приходит но ты нажимаешь скачать не скачаешь потому что там его нету просто не нажмешь эту ссылку
Maxim Sagibgareev: проверить протестировать
Александр Бондаренко: протестировать но я бы я просто думал что я в моменте сделаю воскресенье но я бы так не сделал все равно бы в любом случае потому что мы увидели спрос типа это не суть важно то есть
Александр Бондаренко: ну мы просто дошли он просто отдельно о файлик типа знаете как интернет не погрузился у телеграм на
Maxim Sagibgareev: выбывает кстати я хочу вам еще рассказать общался тоже про всякие вебинары чуваки все там 150 тысяч это стоит программа рублей вот там много -много и горит все в субботу стартуем и
Maxim Sagibgareev: чувак такой пишет пятница или четверг ребят короче тут что -то этот подустал немного вам будет тоже все лучше если вы перенесем на неделю и перенес на неделю просто тоже
Александр Бондаренко: так бывает реально пока у нас не 100 тысяч человек подписалась на вебину типа мы вот пока у нас не 100 человек не 200 мы вообще имеем право так законно сделать и для понимания я же
Александр Бондаренко: захожу проверяют никто из тех людей кто подписался и получил этот как его ну вот нажал на кнопку скачать и у него не получилось никто не отписался всем всех активный статус подписан
Александр Бондаренко: то есть никто не не не вышел из под то есть все как бы ну окей придет попозже наверное не знаю конечно
Maxim Sagibgareev: другой вопрос сколько
Александр Бондаренко: из не дойдет давай бы это тоже отдельная метрика но я
Maxim Sagibgareev: смотри набор набор людей в чате тоже важно это как бы у тебя же тоже мы с водилом смотрели у тебя есть есть такое понятие как моя проблема например да а второе понятие мое ощущение
Maxim Sagibgareev: что у меня есть проблема
Александр Бондаренко: и
Maxim Sagibgareev: это разные типы вещи
Александр Бондаренко: вот
Maxim Sagibgareev: и получается когда ты посмотришь просто на например там вот main experts там 200 человек для ощущения что группа есть 1000 человек она есть какая разница не могут быть все неактивны
Александр Бондаренко: ощущение
Maxim Sagibgareev: то все равно есть как встречает по одежке я вот об этом хотел сказать
Александр Бондаренко: поэтому это
Maxim Sagibgareev: тоже хороший показатель то что они подписались и не отписались видят количество людей которые
Игорь А.: подписаны это вот то есть они
Maxim Sagibgareev: один на один как глазами а это не то но тогда говорил про про
Игорь А.: группу да я понял там где
Maxim Sagibgareev: социальными вот этими доказательствами можно
Игорь А.: раздуть и цифру подписок этом лайки какие -то понятно ну не
Maxim Sagibgareev: то что умысленно да ну просто что это тоже фактор принять решение ну хорошо то есть они подписались на бот ботом отправил файлик они его не получили написали в личку ну
Александр Бондаренко: кто там написал прямо написал типа там hello там ттт один но все остальные я вижу что они пытались скачать по
Maxim Sagibgareev: -русски по английски
Александр Бондаренко: один написал по -английски но все остальные видно что в целом русские там людьми вот так ну -ка кейт ольга елена кстати вот несколько я могу за это мы же и вложить их телеграмм я могу
Александр Бондаренко: прям заходить на каждого кликать билим бур бибину
Maxim Sagibgareev: ну смотрите в общем давайте так пройдемся у нас там садил просто кипят задачу вас на рада же у у меня мысли такие какие запросы вот какой у вас у двоих вектор на этот первый вебинар
Maxim Sagibgareev: какой вам что вам нужно чтобы было для вас и ну понятно что мы там обкатываем и так далее все но просто чего вы хотите какие цели там получить вот и чтобы что я должен сделать тоже
Maxim Sagibgareev: ваша цель можете мне потом расписать коротко там пет 1 и 15 2 15 3 15 минут можете так пробить если хотите я думаю что да так и нужно
Александр Бондаренко: какую -то презентацию сделать я думаю что основная цель это вот свериться но рассказать какую -то контентную часть полезную людям чтобы ну посмотреть что им реально интересно
Maxim Sagibgareev: они остаются
Александр Бондаренко: там задают вопросы все остальное и сделать им какое -то предложение но то есть вот мы определяем что мы там не знаю профориентацию подаем за 50 у нас ты уже готова на
Maxim Sagibgareev: профориентации ну
Александр Бондаренко: конечно ну почему нет там
Maxim Sagibgareev: у нас это что давно
Александр Бондаренко: окей
Maxim Sagibgareev: профориентация скорее всего с личным разбором правильно
Александр Бондаренко: можно так вполне себе парить
Maxim Sagibgareev: чай вижу да продукты какие мы уже потестили простую сырую профориентацию там 5 10 тысяч у нас идет в принципе на горячие продажи такой может быть за 20 можно продать можно продавать
Maxim Sagibgareev: то есть мы сейчас еще получается введем на вебинар чтобы прогрев есть конверсия в вебинар вебинар уже типа а она идет через шаг этого чек -листа правильно ну
Игорь А.: да чек -лист просто
Александр Бондаренко: как подарок там типа запишитесь на вебинар и получите подарок вот такой чек -лист
Maxim Sagibgareev: клиста не пошел и дурь это же лид магнит ты сам говорил да
Александр Бондаренко: они
Maxim Sagibgareev: получают ценность все они получили бесплатно ценность ну но ответ на свой вопрос они не
Игорь А.: получили еще ответ
Maxim Sagibgareev: на свой вопрос еще не получили так окей теперь они идут в вебинар конверсия вебинар может быть получасовой может какой -то базовый можем сделать по всякому как до полутора часов
Игорь А.: час 20 это самое золотое время то есть либо слишком длинные там три четыре часа либо там час час двадцать вот так ну
Maxim Sagibgareev: хорошо надо смотреть насколько там будет людей я пристани против сделать любой продолжительности потому что проговорить а тут много чего есть вопрос наверно еще дальше то есть я к чему
Maxim Sagibgareev: то что у тебя есть линейка продуктов которые конвертируют например там реклама была где -то потом пришли в группу в группе согрелись почитали там какой -нибудь первый offer не знаю
Maxim Sagibgareev: 15 часовая ли там часовая консультация 5000 со мной индивидуальный разбор и потом на этом разборе эти говорю ну там либо еще разбор и мы типа коучинга идет у нас либо все -таки программа
Maxim Sagibgareev: коучинга еще чего -то там программы сопровождения или программа профориентационные еще что -то там 200000 вот там два месяца то есть из моего опыта сейчас в принципе вести коучинг ну
Maxim Sagibgareev: как бы тысяч за 20 за 30 я готов и один раз в две недели достаточно полезно начать это как бы отдельный продукт просто говорю не обязательно сейчас можно продать вадим тоже подключается
Maxim Sagibgareev: на профориентацию продать ну лучше с разговором
Александр Бондаренко: то есть лучше
Maxim Sagibgareev: с медведой и мы это все запишем и вам тоже будет понимать понять понятнее.
Александр Бондаренко: Вот еще раз тоже для полного понимания. Сейчас я открою.
Игорь А.: Пока Саша открывает, я вот такую вводную часть скажу, что обычно как раз вводная часть и знакомит ведущего вебинара с аудиторией. Пока вот как раз все подключаются и идет вот это дело.
Игорь А.: Так, так, всем привет, так, как меня слышно, поставьте плюсики, если слышите, там или единички, все, вижу, единички пошли. Так, значит, меня все слышно, видно, у меня может быть небольшая
Игорь А.: задержка, потому что трансляция идет с небольшой задержкой, там, до полутора -двух минут, поэтому сейчас, когда вы меня слышите, можете написать, кто из какого города. Так, Москва вижу,
Игорь А.: ага, там, Дубай вижу, хорошо, международная.
Maxim Sagibgareev: вопрос пока держи мысль сейчас будешь говорить дальше вопрос такой они все пришли прочитав какую как бы что их поймала то есть какая -то в любой
Александр Бондаренко: вуза мира
Maxim Sagibgareev: на что не
Александр Бондаренко: смотрите прямо в чат
Maxim Sagibgareev: в флузилку
Александр Бондаренко: открываю
Maxim Sagibgareev: сейчас далее
Игорь А.: как раз
Maxim Sagibgareev: таки идет
Вадим Х.: диалог
Игорь А.: на тему того что а у кого какой сейчас актуальный самый актуальный запрос у кого какие там возрастом дети какие у вас запросы и дети и начинают писать люди а
Maxim Sagibgareev: там у всех есть доступ к тому что пишут вы контролируете чат ну мне нравится ваш подход приход мне все понятно тут как бы офигенно оформлено принципе ну
Вадим Х.: разбираем поступление
Maxim Sagibgareev: реальные примеры я просто буду приводить разные примеры все
Игорь А.: актуально
Maxim Sagibgareev: будем приводить примеры да и мне
Игорь А.: нравится история с как раз таки консультациями возможно их две можно даже продавать вырисовываются как бы у меня в голове три пакета первый пакет это вы можете просто сами эту профориентацию
Игорь А.: приобрести вот она там 20 тысяч рублей вы прошли ну
Maxim Sagibgareev: пер кстати можем
Игорь А.: вот эти вот ссылки даже через партнерские вот эти кабинеты сделать, условно говоря, тебя как
Maxim Sagibgareev: партнер и у тебя три ссылки. И мы эти три
Игорь А.: ссылки запускаем в эфир. Значит, вторая это с одной консультацией, то есть вы проходите профориентацию, после этого я вам рассказываю. И третья, самая дорогая, самый дорогой пакет,
Игорь А.: мы сначала с вами общаемся, потом вы проходите профориентацию, потом общаемся там мы там может психолог то есть побольше раз
Maxim Sagibgareev: упаковать если ты хочешь что такое продать упакуй просто чтобы не чтобы было ограничение в услуги ну то есть граница была закончена чтобы это сделаешь я готов мы с одним подключимся
Игорь А.: супер
Александр Бондаренко: супер я не знаю я какую -то энергию ловлю потому что я вижу прям отклик у людей меня он очень нравится мне кажется вот это очень близко к тому чтобы реально попасть целевую аудиторию
Александр Бондаренко: не знаю я скорее
Maxim Sagibgareev: всего не правы ребят как бы все окей идем то есть просто у вас теперь там методика которая сделана под профориентацию будет у вас работать на эксперта у каждого эксперта будем делать
Maxim Sagibgareev: вебинары какие -то английского языка и
Maxim Sagibgareev: посмотрим как бы уже не конвертироваться да почему нет если нам реклама будет выходить дешевле то что мы зарабатываем с аудитории больше то нам выгодно это делать да вот в этом и
Александр Бондаренко: суть вот суть добиться почему я говорил что ну важно сделать на вебинаре продажи чтобы окупить вот этот трафик потому что ну вот реально даже пусть мы его купим все мы понимаем что
Александр Бондаренко: уже на какой -то процент схлопывается мы уже докручиваем следующий раз уже ну там условно можно ставить цель выходить там прям в плюс если мы сейчас прям с этого генера вы не пустой
Александр Бондаренко: вообще будет супер
Александр Бондаренко: короче цель это
Maxim Sagibgareev: я про по форму сейчас уже говорю дальше то есть я
Александр Бондаренко: же тут да я
Maxim Sagibgareev: же тут как бы ну будут все типа эксперты и задачи же чтобы экспертов привлекать партнеров у них же тоже свои продукты есть ну вот то что вы обещаетесь и
Игорь А.: они
Maxim Sagibgareev: тоже все хотят трафик и так далее многие из них готовы на вебинары они на самом деле пробовали но не приходило потому что в чем наша фишка мы можем сделать сообщество
Александр Бондаренко: вот очень
Maxim Sagibgareev: круто
Александр Бондаренко: смотри вот потому что ты говоришь вот не есть из реальности вот я же подписан долгое время был на петраченкова ну вот почти там полгода на закрытый
Maxim Sagibgareev: маркетинговый канал
Александр Бондаренко: и он своем закрытом канале ну сам вот этот вот основатель ведет ну очень редко вебинары но у него почти там каждый там два раза в месяц где -то приходит эксперты которые рассказывают
Александр Бондаренко: вот смотрите в маркетинге круто например аналитика а вот смотрите мы там свою платформу по аналитике собрали мы проводит вот прям вебинар прям закрытом канале и ну там просто вот идите
Александр Бондаренко: там мои это по сути он как бы себя рекламируют свои услуги свою какую -то там штучку интересную ли консультанты
Maxim Sagibgareev: и больше закрывают вопросов которые он не закрывает вот
Александр Бондаренко: вот да да да именно так именно так кто -то по нейронкам пришел по аналитике я
Maxim Sagibgareev: формирую ребят формируется картинка почему выгодно потому что они
Александр Бондаренко: приходят уже на сообщество не знаю что там
Maxim Sagibgareev: в канале 800
Александр Бондаренко: человек упоротых по маркетингу которые прям целевая аудитория им прям вот надо то есть все прибыть приходят смотрят
Maxim Sagibgareev: то есть все кто там подписаны они по сути не просто клиент ну как бы просто потенциально купит они уже что -то купили подписки уже да и каждый месяц платят то есть а сколько они платят
Maxim Sagibgareev: каждый месяц
Александр Бондаренко: с половиной тысячи но мы
Maxim Sagibgareev: можем тоже это сделать
Maxim Sagibgareev: печатает быстренько все кому кому печатать я я я печатаю
Игорь А.: все порядке все
Maxim Sagibgareev: хорошо мне на самом деле такое видение да то есть я недавно тоже смотрел есть прикольные разборы в профессиях там какие -то это канал был чудо типа какая -то меркантильность слышали
Maxim Sagibgareev: что такое
Александр Бондаренко: чувак
Вадим Х.: который
Maxim Sagibgareev: помогает накручивать тебе резюме опыт и так далее чтобы тебя взяли войти
Вадим Х.: на этом смотрели вместе у нет ну
Maxim Sagibgareev: может быть не помню короче суть
Maxim Sagibgareev: в чем многие типа находится на своей должности достаточно долгое время и у них какие -то ограничения есть зарплата не меняется или они не могут зайти в индустрию например новая профессия
Maxim Sagibgareev: появляется там с иишками вот эти мультиагентский подход они например не знакомы с этим мультиагентским подходом просто каком программистом бэкэнда на питоне вот а по факту и он зарабатывает
Maxim Sagibgareev: какую -то иную сумму мы говорим слушай иная сумма плюс тысячу ой плюс 100 тысяч 200 тысяч там в течение месяца двух вот мы тебя ведем и
Maxim Sagibgareev: ты как бы прогрессирует что да это вот я просто вам классический пример сейчас говорю что на рынке работает вот такая работает и ну как бы потом на должности а берут она должен сижить
Maxim Sagibgareev: а проверяют если ты плохо там пишешь это все видно ну как бы тебя могут уволить но не файну не суть как бы многие и хорошие остаются которым так помогли полностью запаковаться и стать
Maxim Sagibgareev: профессионально пригодными ну то есть чтобы их заметили конкурентами так далее это же тоже программа подготовки программа развития
Maxim Sagibgareev: вы со мной сейчас в
Вадим Х.: этой комнате
Александр Бондаренко: вот
Maxim Sagibgareev: и как бы то такое вуз ты идешь вуз чтобы быть подготовленным чтобы тебя взяли трудоустроили когда закончил вуз нахуй ты никому не сдался вот так прям грубо говорю вот вообще никому
Maxim Sagibgareev: не сдался ты более сейчас джуниоры все как бы токены есть какой джуньер проблема когда ты сейчас под давлением непонятно что происходит и тебе так говорит чувак смотри заплатить там
Maxim Sagibgareev: свою зарплату один раз там месячную там не знаю заплатить какую -то иную сумму сейчас и одну сумму по результату например какая -то монетизация все эти буду вести мы тебя доведем я
Maxim Sagibgareev: тебя полностью упакую и как бы подготовлю тебя что ты зашел на новую должность
Александр Бондаренко: там в другом месте и так далее вот он берет поток
Maxim Sagibgareev: какой -нибудь и так делает это вот одна история а другая история ну то есть можно это все делать адекватно то есть внутри мы не накручиваем те не обещаем что ты однозначно поступишь
Maxim Sagibgareev: и получат результат но как бы в целом по нашим кейсом который мы работаем у многих есть такие сложности с переходами не умеют общаться с при интервью потому что это отдельный навык
Maxim Sagibgareev: вот ты конечно же в своей должности но сейчас ты будешь более гибким и потенциально сможешь большую зарплату получить вот твой результат мы тебе его продаем как бы нас уже интересно
Maxim Sagibgareev: рассказывать как на губинаре я уже готов купить да ну все перевозить бабки короче тут сейчас ребята скинут ссылочку насчет студентов тут вопрос сложнее потому что у тебя и опыта нет
Maxim Sagibgareev: и сам ты ну как бы решал задачу в такой безопасной академической среде
Maxim Sagibgareev: вот и в интервью это не умеешь тоже проходить нормально а еще плюс не нанимают представь что нету найма и то есть тебе нужно стремя четырьмя сопротивлениями рынке пройти ну как бы я
Maxim Sagibgareev: не говорю про весь рынок что они занимают конечно не мы но как бы тебе нужно конкурировать и непосредственно к своей специальности тебя должны еще быть какие -то навыки актуальные сейчас
Maxim Sagibgareev: то есть раньше это был там а вы к цели пользуетесь да конечно microsoft там офис умею вот а потом интернет а вы в интернетах умеете работать в мире там а вы сайт умеете сделать умением
Maxim Sagibgareev: ну и так далее в общем короче базовый набор навыков и сейчас вот ну там с искусством интеллекта допустим все равно человеческий фактор важны все равно нужно в профессию зайти и по сути
Maxim Sagibgareev: нашу профориентация как раз таки помогает это то есть это стандарт определенного тестирования который тебя туда доводит и тут ну как бы наша задумка с водилом которая была ну в принципе
Maxim Sagibgareev: это что мы и с вами то 360 помните может это делали 60 это то что ты регулярно можешь делать эксперименты и докручивай точность повышать свою какую нишу ты все -таки хочешь ты хочешь
Maxim Sagibgareev: просто маркетолог или дом маркетолог детских книг
Maxim Sagibgareev: или может все -таки уже не маркетолог потому что месяц прошел ты попробовал себя маркетинге ничего не получилось у тех ребят у них заход какой то что у них есть свой телеграм -канал
Maxim Sagibgareev: там всякие люди смотрят на человека который им рассказывает то что вот я там проработал войти или там я такой -то опыт я знаю как менять профессии как двигаться по карьерной лестнице
Maxim Sagibgareev: он прогревает увеличивает объем своей группы вот его сообщества и он может им все тоже продавать как бы ну как окей у нас идейка такая же тоже то что есть как бы main experts это по
Maxim Sagibgareev: сути разные эксперты и мы пытаемся собрать главных экспертов главные эксперты между собой дружат и у них цель помогать друг другу ну и помогать новичкам новички это все студенты которые
Maxim Sagibgareev: есть которые хотят стать экспертами и пробиться туда и вот ну как бы есть разные пути можешь учиться в школе тоже важный путь к становлению эксперта может пойти в техникум тоже важный
Maxim Sagibgareev: путь получить навыки практичны пойти вуз уже другой уровень там экспертности и ближе там может быть к управленческим должностям тут важны и технические навыки твердые навыки и мягкие
Maxim Sagibgareev: навыки вот и как бы разные зарплатные вилки идут разные направления идут
Игорь А.: как определить то что ты хочешь ну вот наш как раз таки профилитационный продукт 1 2 3 там позволяет это
Maxim Sagibgareev: осуществить первый вопрос сами делаете вы достаточно хорошо там все описали можете пройти с ним не поймёте пишите нам объясним есть продукт конкретно консультацией я его больше всего
Maxim Sagibgareev: рекомендую потому что мы
Игорь А.: там все разъясним и на
Maxim Sagibgareev: многие ваши вопросы тоже ответил у вас будет конкретное понимание не просто бумаги а уже как действовать дальше ближайший год
Maxim Sagibgareev: вот а третий продукт а чё третий был какой -то ты говорил 3
Игорь А.: я говорил изначально консультация с вами до прохождения потом прохождение более осознанная и консультация после разберем посмотрите какого ранте лучше течек приходит вот тебе к тебе
Игорь А.: помню вот и на рынке сейчас просто есть и допустим операционный директор или еще что -то как хочешь вот любую нишу сам назови сейчас давай операционный директор да вот ну типа вот как
Игорь А.: те лучше новичок приходит он хочет получить консультацию
Maxim Sagibgareev: какой -то продукт тебя купить вот чтобы он уже что
Игорь А.: сделал и ты увидел, или чтобы он был сырой, голый и
Maxim Sagibgareev: ты
Игорь А.: с ним познакомился на созвании? Смотри, для меня...
Maxim Sagibgareev: Мы, во -первых, даем рынку, потому что цена разная, и кто -то там смышленый, пошел, пошел, пошел, а кто -то такой, нет, все -таки сопроводите меня за ручку. Но для меня, как, например,
Maxim Sagibgareev: для эксперта, самый лучший вариант, почему я именно этот вариант предлагаю, самый лучший
Александр Бондаренко: вариант это вот мы познакомились и сформирован
Maxim Sagibgareev: запрос с которым дальше мы будем работать потом инструменты
Александр Бондаренко: через которые решается этот
Maxim Sagibgareev: запрос и заключительная сессия то есть что делать дальше
Maxim Sagibgareev: кстати на этой заключительной сессии можно делать до продажу следующего шага
Maxim Sagibgareev: вот линейку продуктов хочется
Александр Бондаренко: давайте со всех спрошу
Maxim Sagibgareev: саш ты эксперт выбирай любую
Александр Бондаренко: экспертизу маркетинге чё хочешь вот начинающий чувак хочет тебя как бы что для тебя важно чтобы ты сделал я как эксперт для типа для клиента но для кого -то может быть еще эксперт для
Александр Бондаренко: мамы мы все эксперты я тоже не не не просто ну для аудитории ну как не для клиента
Maxim Sagibgareev: как бы который сын к хочет твои услуги взять а для пример для молодого эксперта который
Александр Бондаренко: хочет понять как быть таким же крутым как ты если самая главная консультация база консультация и если я понимаю что я могу свою методологию изложить какой -то ну вот как курс
Maxim Sagibgareev: который можно там пройти не важно на видео или текстовый еще какой -то то я бы записал в один раз этот например курс и правил бы такую консультации человек сказал слушай ну если хочешь
Maxim Sagibgareev: прям
Вадим Х.: подробнее добавить 500 сессии это все не размазывал купе просто курс просмотрелы тебе и прокачаешься супер
Maxim Sagibgareev: супер а еще есть закрытый канал а еще и закрытый канал где я кидаю какие -то крутые inside и свяжу за
Вадим Х.: выкидываю новые фишки он вот стоит там я не знаю одну сумму ты подписывайся ты будешь постоянно в курсе прокачиваться там каждый гидиусова смотреть что это новое ну хорошо вадим спасибо
Вадим Х.: наш спасибо игорь вадим тебе такой же вопрос выбери какую -то экспертизу вот и мы твоим продаем данную продаем получалось из пути на обучение они экспертизу не не услугу обучение например
Вадим Х.: мы учим но мы вначале
Maxim Sagibgareev: дало сказать по твоей экспертизе то есть как бы тут это
Вадим Х.: это проемы обучение да да
Maxim Sagibgareev: но мы ему не обучение все правильно получается что мы я вижу похоже на как саша сказал только и только наверное в конце еще добавил бы какой
Игорь А.: -то шаг виде консультации выпускной потому что он может ознакомиться с материалами обучиться наверное
Maxim Sagibgareev: может это итоговая консультация тоже здесь важно может быть здесь можно добавить еще шаг с тестированием итоговым то есть как он эту информацию понял и как и за ибут типа в виде экзамена
Maxim Sagibgareev: и такое подтверждение ну какой -то сертификат от меня хорошо а задайте мне такой же вопрос ну то есть то что мы сейчас с вами делаем кто -то выберите там игорь ты саши вадим как хотите
Maxim Sagibgareev: давай макс какой для тебя идеальный сценарий и идеальный клиент
Maxim Sagibgareev: как
Maxim Sagibgareev: для эксперта правильно да как для эксперта то есть например у меня просто лишь много экспертиз и допустим если я возьму переливаю ну мне
Maxim Sagibgareev: идеально что продаются цифровые продукты вот я сейчас открыл какой -то свою табличку у меня продаются цифровые продукты это могут быть какие -то тестирование еще что -то автоматизированные
Maxim Sagibgareev: да где -то вот она идет и делается продаются наверное какие -то в записи возможно мои курсы вот как саша сказал
Maxim Sagibgareev: есть индивидуальный консультант консультации там энное количество в неделю ну например там раз в день одна консультация но по большой цене
Maxim Sagibgareev: вот может быть еще есть какие -то такие долгие пакеты может быть это они есть как бы просто ну как бы сколько -то людей идет до многие какие -то пакеты там ну да три месяца на 6 месяцев
Maxim Sagibgareev: на 12 месяцев на 369 12 136 19 раз
Вадим Х.: неделю до 1
Maxim Sagibgareev: неделю начало такое приходит да допустим раз в неделю минимально раз неделю вот потом еще какой продукт
Maxim Sagibgareev: такой прям это персональная работа персональное сопровождение то есть он неизвестная вот цена он оценивается отдельно может там миллион стоит может два может три может четыре и тут
Maxim Sagibgareev: прям ну конкретно индивидуальная работа под ключ тут уже экспертиза вадим ты разделил экспертиза которой обучение ну то есть это не экспертиза а тут как раз таки уже экспертиза не обучение
Maxim Sagibgareev: услуги услуги до выполнения каких -то задач к доведения до результата вот ну то есть процесс многим важен но процесс результатов индивидуальные топового эксперта ну
Вадим Х.: как бы он и стоит на рынке дороже потому что
Maxim Sagibgareev: он может открыть то что ты не
Вадим Х.: получишь ну то есть это огромный опыт любимое слово которое сашите забрал насмотренность офигенная ошибок кучу было сделано квалификации миллион потрачено денег миллионы просто квалификации
Вадим Х.: это экспертиза она потом применяется
Maxim Sagibgareev: уже точно
Вадим Х.: под какого -то под какую -то задачу мы
Maxim Sagibgareev: все по сути тут идет своего рода на им эксперта вот такие продукты у меня идут идеальные наверное
Maxim Sagibgareev: ну да
Вадим Х.: я добавил
Maxim Sagibgareev: то что давай наверное очень важно чтобы сама система давала возможность мне удобно и легко
Игорь А.: свои вот эти услуги делать виде продуктов электро и но вот этих автоматизи автоматически визирована она мне помогала и делает ну таким легким процессом добавления и быстро процесса
Игорь А.: добавления ну то есть ты эксперт
Maxim Sagibgareev: в своей экспертизе
Игорь А.: но не эксперт в упаковках и маркетинге и ты бы хотел администрирование все это перевести на на на платформу саму да да так давать круг дальше идем возвращаемся игрок тебе раунд два
Игорь А.: то есть если что -то добавить добавляй такие же вопросы к тебе. Ну, смотрите, опять же, в рамках экспертизы... Я бы сказал, что да, есть, например, линейка, то есть, условно говоря,
Игорь А.: коучинговая сессия, которая более короткая, занимает меньше часов, но стоит тоже. То есть в коучинговой сессии мой час
Maxim Sagibgareev: стоит дороже, и понятное дело, что условно 10 коучинговых сессий принесут мне больше, чем, например, полная занятость.
Maxim Sagibgareev: но чтобы она включала все равно это тет -а -тет с человеком
Игорь А.: да какие -то электронные продукты возможно электронные системы либо инструменты и все равно закрытие этой коучинговой сессии как
Maxim Sagibgareev: план что делать дальше то есть тут у меня ничего не изменилось потому что всегда должен быть у у
Игорь А.: человека на руках такой навигатор, а что дальше с этим делать и какой план стоит. Вот, по поводу линейки. Можешь углубиться в план, что делать дальше? Углубиться в плане,
Игорь А.: ну вот к тебе обратилась тысяча человек, тысяча человек, они все заплатили с тобой, то есть что в себя включает этот план?
Игорь А.: И как бы на чем фокус ты бы здесь держал? Ну, давай так, тогда разделять. Я говорил про, условно говоря, про 10, это вместимость, про 1000, наверное, это уже... Ну, давай так, у тебя
Игорь А.: 10 сейчас есть, 990 в очереди, ну ты видишь, что они есть. Ну, естественно, тогда нужно оцифровывать этот навык. Как вот я оцифровал, условно говоря, свой навык, который мне строят
Игорь А.: теперь файлы, которые
Maxim Sagibgareev: являются процессной картой. Вот. И, скорее всего, я бы тогда делился такими инструментами. Они бы, наверное, стоили дешевле. Но чтобы понимать, что человек
Игорь А.: не
Maxim Sagibgareev: на нейрослопил или херню какую -то не написал, все равно, так как там стоит
Игорь А.: мое имя как создателя данной методологии, хотелось бы с человеком прокоммуницировать. Пусть они даже в очереди, но по крайней мере, условно говоря, 200 часов в месяц, это уже 200 человек,
Игорь А.: за 5 месяцев всех через себя пропустить можно.
Игорь А.: Ну то есть, чтобы что? Чтобы, по сути, качество было? Да, конечно.
Maxim Sagibgareev: То есть проверка качества один на один?
Вадим Х.: Да. То есть человек получил твой цифровой продукт или что,
Игорь А.: или как? Да, человек получил цифровой продукт,
Maxim Sagibgareev: в котором есть
Игорь А.: методология, прошел его, получил свой результат, и сверить, что этот результат ему подходит, и он правильный, с моей точки зрения, с моей экспертизой, вот здесь нужна консультация.
Игорь А.: Может быть, я сейчас, может быть, думаю о том, что и 400 человек можно, то есть время сократить консультацию, условно говоря, до получаса, и таким образом пропускную способность свою
Игорь А.: поднять.
Игорь А.: Так, хорошо.
Maxim Sagibgareev: Результат, который получил, это поясни, что ты мешаешь. Ну,
Игорь А.: мы же говорим про
Maxim Sagibgareev: условный продукт.
Игорь А.: Ну, вот возьмем тот же скилл, который у меня есть, мой навык. Например, я продаю его. То есть человек загрузил задачу, получил процессную карту и получил описание каждого элемента этой
Игорь А.: карты. Вот возьмем вот такой вот навык, которым я действительно пользуюсь, который я для себя создал, которым, кстати, могу с вами поделиться. можете погонять его тоже там вот со своей
Игорь А.: точки зрения вот и например вадим ты его взял и пошел там под свою задачу его использовать оцифрованная компетенция твоя видит продукта который можно там лэнками или еще как то да да
Игорь А.: да да да то есть
Maxim Sagibgareev: вот
Игорь А.: здесь как бы развилка отвечаю ли я за твой результат это как ты
Maxim Sagibgareev: делаешь то есть я могу не
Игорь А.: отвечать и это будет просто цифровой
Maxim Sagibgareev: продукт действительно который стоит недорого ну дешевле а могу отвечать и тогда моя консультация например стоит там определенную сумму и вот тот вопрос который ты поднимаешь условно
Maxim Sagibgareev: говоря про тысячу стоящих очередь значит скорее всего если они действительно готовы оплатить или уже предоплаты пришли, то условно говоря, за полгода
Александр Бондаренко: или там за три месяца я всех обрабатываю, но следующая итерация, я
Maxim Sagibgareev: ставлю цену там ноль справа, условно говоря, чтобы себя
Александр Бондаренко: так не нагружать и работать с
Maxim Sagibgareev: теми людьми, которые
Александр Бондаренко: готовы эту цену покупать дороже. Супер, супер, я тебя остановлю, огонь вообще, круто. Саша, тебе вопрос. Если что -то добавить, ты эксперт, допустим у тебя много экспертиз вот до этого
Александр Бондаренко: ты выбрал одну экспертизу сейчас другую выбери и вот ну по сути те же самые вопросы если что добавить чтобы ты еще хотел идеальный клиент идеальный процесс на неделю
Александр Бондаренко: так сложно другую экспертизу например продажа твою смежную какую -то да какую
Александр Бондаренко: например production допустим там людям то
Maxim Sagibgareev: есть нужно ну какой -то результат то есть наверное в
Александр Бондаренко: этой если вы весь обратить продакшен наверное идеальный клиент они тот человек который видео себе хочет сделать для бизнеса ну если брать вот именно распаковку экспертизы продакшена
Александр Бондаренко: а наверное какой -то подаван
Maxim Sagibgareev: который типа мне есть камера я начинаю снимать и новичок нихрена знаю я могу сказать чувак смотри я вот этот путь прошел вообще с полного нуля там без там профильного образования до
Maxim Sagibgareev: проектов там для зарубежных
Александр Бондаренко: компаний там от там 300 тысяч просто ролик минутный и типа я тебе могу быть я готов уже запустаться к сашу подавать наверное в этом
Maxim Sagibgareev: случае ну
Александр Бондаренко: наверное ну похожая связка наверное начать с консультации рассказать что ну вообще определить на каком этапе человек находится и ну ему прям ближайшее действие подсветить какой финальный
Александр Бондаренко: результат тогда получается консультации будет ну давай 1 2 2 консультации первое вводное знакомство а вторая результативный вот результат 1 вводной и 2 результативный оба результата
Александр Бондаренко: скажи но убить 1 вводный это то есть я человеку прям скажу смотри вот и сейчас вот здесь и ну ты хочешь вот туда допустим ты снимать хочешь там высокобюджетные ролики вот у тебя сейчас
Александр Бондаренко: чек там условно у тебя тупо кейсы за которые ты не получал еще деньги а ты хочешь там ну допустим там до 1 100000 например заработать я бы подсветил я бы посвятил бы набор там от оборудования
Александр Бондаренко: как выбирать до подключат всю историю делать то есть я опять же подсветил бы компетенции бывают же люди которые просто вот я из камерой снимаю не умеет не монтировать а если я видео
Александр Бондаренко: мейкер я все могу под ключ не хочу делать то есть я бы мог посредил план действий как ближайшие там три месяца явно большой шаг сделать как минимум получить
Maxim Sagibgareev: не первые деньги
Александр Бондаренко: результативный
Maxim Sagibgareev: в зависимости не знаю в зависимости от уже дальнейшего запроса вот может быть такое что он пошел три месяца покрутил все я первый из набрал я там ну вот могу снимать могу монтировать
Maxim Sagibgareev: там у меня сейчас сейчас беру на съемку
Александр Бондаренко: как например масштабировать я бы ему рассказал допустим смотри вот варианты как можно масштабировать например ты можешь ставить больше цены делать сложнее продукт а может за ту же цену
Александр Бондаренко: брать больше клиентов и в принципе зарабатывать больше для этого
Maxim Sagibgareev: тебе нужно явно какой -то
Александр Бондаренко: поток сформировать как у вас формировать как типа врать
Maxim Sagibgareev: больше очень круто
Александр Бондаренко: очень круто прям вообще великолепно
Maxim Sagibgareev: ты сейчас это
Александр Бондаренко: рассказал ну то есть давай так когда ты говоришь это подаван
Maxim Sagibgareev: то есть опиши кто какой там возраст
Александр Бондаренко: кто это такой
Maxim Sagibgareev: ну вот именно вот у меня были случаи я же когда
Александр Бондаренко: продакшен вел у меня я очень активно
Maxim Sagibgareev: вел instagram то есть я прям
Александр Бондаренко: каждую съемку я всегда что -то снимал вот мы коптер запускаем вот мы кран для каменную типа нацепили на кран камеру вот смотрите она как кино снимает там
Maxim Sagibgareev: вот
Александр Бондаренко: я на съемку еду 5 день уже всем утра там 6 утра встаю
Александр Бондаренко: я выкладывал в инстаграме принц шорт у меня там все вот мы с челом едем на кабриолете
Александр Бондаренко: да да да у меня много сохраненок на больше в архиве видосов да конечно мне там очень насыщенная жизнь одного летнего парня ну реально на меня подписывались чуваки и
Maxim Sagibgareev: они были были чувак это так круто типа я хочу также я смотрю эти чуваки уже там я уже давно перестал заниматься они до сих пор занимаются они там ну типа крутые уже съемка с нейросетями
Maxim Sagibgareev: баку точно я для кем -то являлся вот таким типа вдохновляющим какой степени например а
Александр Бондаренко: потому что мне был 21
Maxim Sagibgareev: год и типа я уже там два года на тот момент он занимался и тут рядом и в москве у меня съемки были и в краснодаре там я коровку из кореновских будет снимают а вот для
Александр Бондаренко: буфа какая -то съемка, а вот для этого Сергей Лазарев, а тут вот Эбби, международная компания, типа,
Александр Бондаренко: поручно, насыщенно. Ну, классные кейсы были такие, как бы, у многих и такого не было, ну, ввиду своего, своих выборов, которые они делали, а ты делал
Вадим Х.: по -другому. И,
Александр Бондаренко: как бы, в принципе, твой образ,
Maxim Sagibgareev: ну, и реальность твоя, она более позитивная, в чем -то более ценная, и они хотят получить эту ценность, хотят... тот образ который ты формируешь ну как бы к себе при притянуть и говорят
Maxim Sagibgareev: ну записываются к себе образа на консультацию какую -то ли там
Вадим Х.: я проводил
Maxim Sagibgareev: обучение по монтажу и то есть ко мне прям я больше пяти или семи человек вот я прям под ключ обучил обучил монтажу вот сейчас вот назад оглядываюсь я думаю блин я мог
Александр Бондаренко: уже тогда начать делиться вот как сейчас вот эти
Maxim Sagibgareev: беру сказал что для начинающих чуваков рассказывать как вот типа начать я мне тогда просто в голову не пришло это не так сильно развита было ну типа но просто это вот я бы хотел то
Maxim Sagibgareev: сейчас ребята давай обратим внимание потому что реально вот тоже не сейчас сказал вот то что ты сейчас к зал это чита ради чего нужна платформы да это не задумывается это одно я немножко
Maxim Sagibgareev: другом это о том чтобы как раз таки задумываться что ты можешь и поделиться тоже своим опытом да да и не просто задумывается чувак вообще
Александр Бондаренко: расслабься мы за тебя уже тут все продумали мы знаем все циклы мы знаем что нужно аудитории вот у нас есть прикольные нам вебинары конкретно как вообще экспертиза формируется как экспертиза
Александр Бондаренко: нужно делиться как за это зарабатывать и так далее приходи вот и внешний чувак на улице там ты занимаешься классно видео а хочет зарабатывать там больше не хочешь вклад все -таки внести
Александр Бондаренко: этот и за деньги одно а вклад общество даешь или нет карман позитивно или позитивно
Александр Бондаренко: утрирую и все это добыть я вывлете тогда было при так что тот и и мы тебе сейчас какой -то оффер даем вот я я тоже я фоном думаю ты говоришь я подумал а как меня можно было бы тогда
Александр Бондаренко: вовлечь лисе миск вот у меня тогда цель была вот я хочу больше зарабатывать хочу машину
Maxim Sagibgareev: купить хочу квартиру там какую -то первую и то есть я думал чтобы мне больше зарабатывать не там
Александр Бондаренко: нужно там именно как бизнес обязательно выстроить сложную конструкцию по продакшен сложным 100 проектов в месяц я не знаю и типа либо супер со знаменитостями
Maxim Sagibgareev: работать там на меньше проектов если бы мне сказали саша вот
Вадим Х.: смотри у тебя сейчас уже есть огонь опыт
Александр Бондаренко: хотя никто так я помню говорим что типа там свой был какой синдром самозванца если мне сказать что смотрите свой опыт уже сейчас можешь там там 200
Maxim Sagibgareev: минимум только на этой теме там зарабатывать вообще там 300 спокойно ну прям вот просто отделясь своим опытом судьи я бы тогда вовлекся у меня был дании не так сказали тогда ты бы не
Maxim Sagibgareev: вовлекся до конца тебе уже говорили ну не ну мне говорили что огонь саша у тебя опыт ты крут вот так мне говорили но мне никто не говорю что типа огонь саша у тебя опыт ты можешь на
Maxim Sagibgareev: этом зарабатывать больше вот вот смотри где и вот смотри где его смотри как да да да да да да вот вот это важно вот смотри как это как как ты можешь я бы тогда наверное может быть и
Maxim Sagibgareev: нет может и прав макс но как бы а тут больше ну два фактора то два фактора то есть первый фактор я молодой зеленый мир огромные и страшные неизвестный и поэтому сложно в мире все и
Maxim Sagibgareev: чтобы сложность решить нужно прокачаться стать понимающим что а на самом деле я сам же картинку про мир то себе создал когда молодой зеленый Мир на самом деле сложный, и он не такой
Maxim Sagibgareev: простой. Но тот, кто уже с этим миром работает в индустрии, в какой -то специфике, решает определенный набор задач, для него этот мир уже структурирован. Там много неизвестности, но
Maxim Sagibgareev: все равно, когда ты под Овану передаешь это, то есть это не абстрактно, ну как бы всего много, как бы что тут делать. А вот конкретно тебе план на неделю, например. ну что я вижу общаясь
Maxim Sagibgareev: с студентами у многих прям как
Александр Бондаренко: бы себя вспоминаю типа в детстве
Maxim Sagibgareev: ограничение идет то что тут провал может быть какой -то да что такое ну или
Игорь А.: просто банальное незнание вот просто вот чисто безграмотность и исходя из этого малой информации мало насмотренности принятие решений в ограниченном таком моем опыте еще подростковым
Игорь А.: она конечно же такое знаешь очень может быть обережливо осторожное и когда я
Maxim Sagibgareev: зарабатываю да у меня есть деньги например хочу больше блин ну это же сложно и все как бы на это а у меня зубов и какой -то примеры
Игорь А.: вот такого успеха то есть так как примера вот такого не было похожего какого -то чувака были примеры там онлайн школу уже таких самых первых таких древнецких но они были такие сложно
Игорь А.: то есть там курс на два месяца там сложно тебе все рассказывают я сам записывался там на вылет еще прикиньте курс на вылет типа не сделал вылетел на 4 недели типа я думаю это же очень
Игорь А.: типа мне нужно x10 наверное экспертности меня там я не знаю пять лет отпахать типа я такой блин то есть мне не приходило в голову что нужно сильно проще сделать вот не было такого примера
Игорь А.: и типа
Игорь А.: монтажу
Maxim Sagibgareev: и по съемке как -то узко наверное мне вообще не приходило
Игорь А.: в голову что можно вообще концепцию поменять и супер я бы хотел чтобы игорь включился и говорю как бы все что ты слышишь добавь
Maxim Sagibgareev: у меня тоже были такие курсы на вылеты я где -то даже вылетал таков рынок был он меняется и чё я хочу сказать с
Игорь А.: одной стороны то что ведет к прогрессу ускорению всякие наши яички я сейчас вообще у меня мысли в другую сторону просто улетели они стороны ускоряют нас людей У которых какая -то экспертиза
Игорь А.: жизненная
Maxim Sagibgareev: есть.
Игорь А.: Но с другой стороны, я, глядя на своих детей, думаю, а как им будет наработать весь этот опыт, не пройдя через весь этот мыслительный процесс,
Игорь А.: который им как результат сейчас дает ИИШКО. Будут ли они быстрее? Это вообще общество другого какого -то типа
Maxim Sagibgareev: будет. которая, возможно, ну они еще умеют, условно говоря, там считать таблицу умножения, там какие -то базовые вещи, но я просто задумываюсь о младшем, когда через 7 лет он пойдет,
Maxim Sagibgareev: через 6 лет пойдет в школу, а через 20 будет заканчивать там вуз, я просто думаю, какое будет это. Ты про лестницу развития компетенций? Да, просто насколько они вообще будут востребованы,
Александр Бондаренко: или мы, как люди умные, условно говоря, такое же тоже было со всякими революциями, когда вырезали,
Maxim Sagibgareev: наоборот, старшее поколение.
Вадим Х.: Ну
Maxim Sagibgareev: да, надеюсь, что тут такого не будет. Мы не будем загадывать прям
Александр Бондаренко: далеко, но проблемы
Maxim Sagibgareev: актуальны, то, что ты говоришь. Я просто... Про детей, про... Да, а вот... Ну, просто меня уносит в какие -то крайности, условно говоря. Вот происходит исчезновение электронной техники.
Maxim Sagibgareev: Ну, я просто детям примеры, зачем нужно учиться. Говорю, вот просто какой -то вирус или еще что -нибудь. Или пришлось отключить, потому что AI далеко зашел. Ну, вот отключили. С чем
Maxim Sagibgareev: вы останетесь? То есть, с какими знаниями вы будете? И, ну, с одной стороны, круто. как и куда показывать, но точно наработка собственных навыков и компетенций, неважно, суровые это
Maxim Sagibgareev: условия или какие -то лайтовые, ну, разные, вот раньше было так, сейчас там по -другому и так далее. Я на самом деле хотел чуть -чуть тебя, не сбивая, да, то есть держи мысль тоже,
Maxim Sagibgareev: добавить один момент, и то, что я слышу, он такой глобального на самом деле глубины, я думаю сашка тебе тут видео смотрел классным парнем как начать делать видео с нуля я скинул нам
Maxim Sagibgareev: группу и азарь сакой да да да тоже вы даже одна фамилица вот это да я и да и да забавно Вадим видел это нет нет нет нет 7 лет назад было это
Игорь А.: вот посмотри коротко посмотри потому что это крутой редактор режиссер оператор прекрасный человек там да там много интересных если вдруг захочешь видео стоит короче смотрите какая тема
Игорь А.: войти войти да а по факту войти войти а если ты выдел вышел из зайти ты тоже можешь жить как бы вот и онлайн важен онлайн важен и сейчас парадигма меняется оффлайн важен даже вот
Maxim Sagibgareev: недавно там кто -то
Игорь А.: скидывал рекламу и
Maxim Sagibgareev: увидел
Игорь А.: об и найм у них был там 400000 в год долларов за мероприятие организатора мероприятий живых мероприятий в живую всяких ивентов то
Игорь А.: есть я вижу уже у многих
Maxim Sagibgareev: ну как бы кто там айтишники кто крутые с технологиями там кто в безопасности там работает они там увольняются уходят образом лес или там уходит помогать людям или там за открывать свои
Maxim Sagibgareev: садики школы то есть тут как бы крайности крайностями если в целом взять общий тренд то важно тебе уметь жить и с технологиями без технологий и с людьми и с агентами
Maxim Sagibgareev: вот хотел просто добавить то что ты сказал сейчас игорь непонятное дело что вот тот же пример с лошадьми он как раз таки актуален да вот появились машины или с радио да когда там в
Maxim Sagibgareev: В 30 -х годах эти лейблы крупные договорились, что их певцы, которые состоят в этих лейблах, не будут на радио крутиться. И тогда выросли, наоборот, маленькие независимые лейблы, которые
Maxim Sagibgareev: крутились на радио.
Игорь А.: На радио, да, и таким образом, условно
Вадим Х.: говоря, классическая там оркестровая музыка
Maxim Sagibgareev: ушла на второй план, потому что как бы появились независимые артисты, которых начали крутить, люди начали танцевать рок -н -ролл. Ну, свинк -н -ролл там всякие предыдущие эти. Ну, это
Maxim Sagibgareev: же тема какая, потому что есть экосистема, если мы берём вот такой экосистемный подход, причём с биологией, с биологией. И в экосистеме есть разные участники. И у всех у них есть разные
Maxim Sagibgareev: потребности, и у самой среды тоже есть разные ресурсы, возможности, которые она даёт. Например, у тебя есть способ удовлетворения этих потребностей. И как бы к чему я говорю, то что
Maxim Sagibgareev: нам не обязательно ну вот как бы есть подход такой как это темплей ты да то есть у тебя детали могут меняться а общий pipeline общими механика одинаково и если мы как бы по сути создаем
Maxim Sagibgareev: волну и то нам неважно на ней на лодке плавают или на ней серфер есть или вы еще кто то то есть если мы экосистему как бы видим и помогаем в экосистеме всем раскрываться то
Maxim Sagibgareev: как бы тут и радио хорошо и начинающие молодые новые старые доход какие решения принимайте хоть кому что там говорите ну как бы это это возможно и так и так может до
Maxim Sagibgareev: судьбы и
Вадим Х.: компетенции да
Maxim Sagibgareev: можем начать просто с какого -то ядра которая нам близко которая нам нужна ну как бы я считаю там как бы что я слышу на слуху да очень круто большие деньги там и агенты кто умеет разрабатывать
Maxim Sagibgareev: там качественно вот я смотрел я недавно общался у меня родственник есть который в альфа -банке работает он как внешний такой внешний сотрудник там через организацию нанимают вот он
Maxim Sagibgareev: разрабатывает и агентов и он говорит альфа -банком как бы уже как бы просто чисто чтобы быть в теме она не отстают то есть какие -то вещи которые хочешь делать в клиентском сервисе
Maxim Sagibgareev: но они как бы отстают от рынка потому что берешь тоже самый там ты банк если ты хочешь какую -то задачу все решить документ какой -то сделать у тебя мультиагентская система его быстро
Maxim Sagibgareev: сделает и даст достаточно ну там глубокой сложности и они ее внутри разработали а у них она там допустим слабая ну я те к чему то что есть определенные сейчас тренды как бы компетенций
Maxim Sagibgareev: которые по сути могут позволять
Maxim Sagibgareev: работнику переговорном формате иметь преимущество
Maxim Sagibgareev: при найме и по сути образно диктовать свою цену
Maxim Sagibgareev: поясни какие ну -ка то который вас не было примеры есть спрос например вот я тебе говорю что связано там там консультантов до хрена в свободном плавании консультанты которые делают
Maxim Sagibgareev: бывшие бывшие специалисты например ушли свободное плавание не всегда они могут тоже самый создать его продать чтобы тебе продать просто продукта как вы видите не хватает вот то есть
Maxim Sagibgareev: как видно по нашему кейсу нужны связи то есть нужна аудитория клиентская база какая -то и продукт и тогда ты можешь на связях на доверие продавать что -то и вот у тебя есть много разных
Maxim Sagibgareev: экспертов которых есть разные экспертизы какие -то из них на растущем рынке их экспертизы востребованы какие -то на падающем рынке либо на
Вадим Х.: начинающем рынке у них нет экспертиз и как раз таки вот для чего ну сообщество и нужно
Maxim Sagibgareev: почему эти эксперты важны они могут это передавать вот
Maxim Sagibgareev: поэтому как бы тут насчет экспертиз вроде сказала не знаю понятно или нет какие там другие экспертизы но я думаю трансформация будет именно смежная но как мы видим по нашли с ваших
Maxim Sagibgareev: с вами работе то что у тебя
Вадим Х.: есть как бы как я вижу до экспертизы смотрите есть
Maxim Sagibgareev: реальная экспертиза а есть поддержка экспертиза вот все что поддержка экспертиза это рутина вся рутина будет уходить то есть уже кейсы какие то что то же самый битрик 24 сократили там
Maxim Sagibgareev: штат клиентского сервиса не потеряв качество ну то есть тут очень важно совокупности показатели смотреть то что у тебя оттока не
Вадим Х.: увеличилась от тебе
Maxim Sagibgareev: потенциально неизменный остался удовлетворенность клиентской базы осталось такой же и вот ты внедрил новые технологии или там ты внедрил что -то в систему и у тебя есть какая -то экономическая
Maxim Sagibgareev: выгода но по сути это увольнение либо продажи какие -то автоматизированные либо увольнение ну что ты эффективнее использовал ресурс который то
Александр Бондаренко: есть
Maxim Sagibgareev: и на им других специалистов
Александр Бондаренко: получается другого профиля поддерживать
Maxim Sagibgareev: уже а его леду то есть смотри что это дает эти технологии то что у многих компаний у них нет он остановился на им увольнение нету то есть обычно когда устанавливается там на им еще
Maxim Sagibgareev: увольнение добавляются а тут этого нету как потому что ты можешь увеличить эффективность просто существующих ресурсов то есть компетенции растут у этих людей которые остаются и технологии
Maxim Sagibgareev: позволяют тебе не
Maxim Sagibgareev: обязательно даже то что компетенции растут логике позволяет выполнять всю цепочку
Игорь А.: всех
Maxim Sagibgareev: процессов
Maxim Sagibgareev: всеми же компетенции ну частично растущим я думаю не растут на рода на не все равно растут вы не важно растут выставляет появляется новый на наверное появляется новый получается
Maxim Sagibgareev: трансформация вот классное слово трансформация происходит И по факту, зачем тебе идти к наставнику, вот то, что ты говоришь, Саш,
Maxim Sagibgareev: подаван, ну ты же ты для него наставник. Зачем мне брать какого -то эксперта, ну потому что я клиент, который не умеет так.
Maxim Sagibgareev: Это вопрос?
Maxim Sagibgareev: Ну я так обдумываю, мысли кидаю. Риторический. Риторический, да.
Maxim Sagibgareev: Ну, если вернуться к тому, что у нас сейчас возможно. да то есть у нас на платформе как бы мы партнерскую систему на делаем сейчас это круто как раз таки сейчас ее протестим сейчас
Maxim Sagibgareev: будет вебинар посмотрим как ну как как будет как вебинарская тема идет и
Вадим Х.: потом надо думать внутри какие
Maxim Sagibgareev: -то продукты но оставлять начать базы и можно идти вот в этот main experts как бы какой -то на расширение непосредственно вот самого как соотечество линейки продуктов которая может
Maxim Sagibgareev: быть полезна линейка продуктов платформы с линейкой продуктов знаешь какая может быть у меня у меня есть гипотеза нести пользу то что движущий как бы в каждом бизнесе есть какой -то
Maxim Sagibgareev: какая -то корова которая дает молоко локомотив обычно называем локомотив да да да да ну там разные уровни в линейке у тебя bc тоже есть кто приносит больше выручки там и так далее вот
Александр Бондаренко: мне видится
Maxim Sagibgareev: несколько гипотез то есть первое это ну теперь энный период берите годовые консультации просто энные консультации пакеты с консультациям и упаковка такая то что ты разговариваешь с
Maxim Sagibgareev: экспертом и по сути сокращаешь себе путь в профессию это первое а второе даже первое это было второе а первое ты понимаешь вообще малыми экспериментами твое ли это
Maxim Sagibgareev: то есть как будто бы мало эксперименты это другая услуга нет не такая ну как пауки снесусь то есть если услуга в английскому
Александр Бондаренко: поучиться то
Maxim Sagibgareev: есть не нужно прокачать навыки тут есть задача я хочу биология будущем заниматься с биологом пообщаться
Maxim Sagibgareev: консультации и вот для консультация что внутри консультации эксперимент это по сути упражнение я делаю это упражнение или набор этих упражнений и смотрю как бы насколько она мне подходит
Maxim Sagibgareev: хочу ли его делать качали те мышцы которые хочу может быть я буду сопротивляться меня там
Вадим Х.: как наставник как эксперт доведет до какого -то результатов но как где -то вот здесь вот гипотез закрутятся то есть я не говорю что это прям эксперимент это мы методологически это называем
Вадим Х.: эксперимент по
Maxim Sagibgareev: факту короткие
Вадим Х.: урл занятия короткие консультации параллельно твоим университетом и всему остальному в рамках твоего развития в рамках твоего ну там академического развития потом уже карьерного ты
Вадим Х.: задумываешься где буду профессионалом дальше за что мне будут платить дальше и тут у тебя варианты а хочу ли я вообще быть таким профессионалом вот у тебя есть комьюнити допустим где
Вадим Х.: -то есть там визуально посмотреть что они делают и так далее ты такой блин прикольно то какие стандартные кейсы почему я начал пройти говорить потому что это мои агенты они на самом
Вадим Х.: деле ну то есть можно собрать миллионы только вот на этой вот ниши я думаю
Вадим Х.: то есть тоже самое творите меньше учителя английского языка мы собрали там 100 человек вот и у нас есть определенная специфика учителя английского языка
Maxim Sagibgareev: мы собрали
Вадим Х.: вот там психологов
Maxim Sagibgareev: профориентологов лес есть своя какая это определенная история собрали программистов которые хотят делиться своим опытом и помогать понимать куда идти дальше молодым солистам вот что
Maxim Sagibgareev: -то такое приходит
Maxim Sagibgareev: давайте здесь круто крут крут крут можно мысли быстренько скажу круто это вяжется с про ориентацией и вот это услугу, о которой ты говоришь, такая вот организация проб. Не любишь это
Maxim Sagibgareev: слово, Макс. Ну проб, экспериментов давай с чем -то.
Maxim Sagibgareev: Профессиональных экспериментов и проб, да. То есть эта услуга именно получается платформы, а мы уже подбираем там разных экспертов. И еще мне здесь нравится связь с тем, что мы делаем
Maxim Sagibgareev: по Маше. Это построение видения. То есть пробы это одна как бы часть, а вторая часть это показать картинку человек показать видение его будущего вот в этой профессии это очень круто
Maxim Sagibgareev: мне кажется это она тоже одно на одно она отлаивается и позволяет человеку увидеть вообще его не его все вместе очень круто и начинается с прохориентации то есть вот у тебя там несколько
Maxim Sagibgareev: направлений вот у тебя твоих да вот у тебя несколько допустим три направления по каждому из них мы можем тебе организовать пробу по каждому из них мы тебе рисуем картинку будущего твоего
Maxim Sagibgareev: и ты видишь что я буду такой и попробовал еще ну какой -то ну а давайте давай опустим это ребятам вот смотрите ребят тоже вы подключаетесь саш вот ты недавно скидывал как ты с нейронкой
Maxim Sagibgareev: она тебе так планчик такой делает там сколько -то шагов тык -тык -тык вот представь что это пакет и у тебя есть пакета у него название какое -то там ну допустим у тебя там свое у меня
Maxim Sagibgareev: вот как раз вебинар который вы сейчас и делаете и это вебинар по сути он может быть индивидуальные 5 занятий вот он пакет
Maxim Sagibgareev: поступил в любой вуз мира там пять уроков стоимость такая консультации там с тем -то и И как бы вот что -то к такому приходит, что вот они продукты какие -то. Но опять же вопрос открытый
Maxim Sagibgareev: к вам, потому что упаковкой занимаетесь вы.
Maxim Sagibgareev: Саш, ты и Игорь, ты.
Maxim Sagibgareev: Я вам говорю как бы со стороны производства, то, что мы видим, то, что запросы на это есть. То, что когда мы производим, ну как бы идем к профессии через университеты, магистратуру,
Maxim Sagibgareev: бакалавриат, колледж, школа. там
Вадим Х.: садик да вот то есть
Maxim Sagibgareev: это все разные маршруты все прошли через это кто эксперт своими путями но примерно прошли через похоже потом они трудились и делали какие -то задачи выполняли какие -то работы ездили
Maxim Sagibgareev: там как ты там рассказываешь снимали это на видео все у них какая -то история сохранилась вот молодым ну и вообще непонятно вот прям вот но если там не футболист какой -то это это прямо
Maxim Sagibgareev: отдельно должно быть занятие то есть человеком кто -то должен поговорить рассказать ему поделиться может быть замотивировать и ну сказать ему что потенциально не стоит делать и тут
Maxim Sagibgareev: может быть не один эксперт в пакете тут может быть много разных людей с каким он может поговорить может быть потому что есть специализация например в биологии вот то что мы сейчас там
Maxim Sagibgareev: есть экология потом есть
Вадим Х.: городская какая -то экология, потом есть животные, которые живут в море, морские твари,
Вадим Х.: лесополоса. И по сути, уровень специализации каждого из них это отдельная специализация. То есть тот, кто там очень крутой, в одной, скорее всего, будет менее крутой в другой. Я говорю
Maxim Sagibgareev: уровень исследовательский, который прямо вот
Вадим Х.: уже либо новые знания создают, а если это профессиональная сфера, новую ценность создают какую -то. эксперт по жукам что эксперт
Вадим Х.: жукам по жукам
Maxim Sagibgareev: по жукам по всяким
Вадим Х.: этим по по группе
Maxim Sagibgareev: животных то есть слушаем я считаю что
Вадим Х.: самые крутые это там какие -то хвостатые рептилии все
Maxim Sagibgareev: вот я вот готов
Вадим Х.: рептилиями заниматься всем остальным мы ему и говорим смотри вот этот чувак он работает там в оон или еще где -то там
Игорь А.: в каком -то организации wwf ну там вот он у нас на платформе тоже есть вот у него есть консульта он может тебя вести
Maxim Sagibgareev: там пару ну там год может с тобой
Игорь А.: красный деле будет созваниваться
Maxim Sagibgareev: с ним вот либо бери пакет просто пять занятий посмотри проговоришь все с ним тебя часов хватит принципе обсудить просто киона и вопросы ответа а там решите какие дальше 5 занятий что
Maxim Sagibgareev: там будет внутри ему как бы сами уже определитесь все он пошел заниматься слушай есть такая платформа забыл называется там как раз таки вот такие люди сами себя публикуют я там такой
Maxim Sagibgareev: такой крутой челу можете написать типа такого вот но они его они больше себя выкладывают платформа смысла в том что они выкладывают себя что пиарится то есть и нет нет их их находят
Maxim Sagibgareev: сми сми то есть они идут таки так нам нужно взять интервью какого -то крутого там эколога всемирного а вот они вышли там вот мы там nbc какой -нибудь дайте нам типа ну этот какой -то
Maxim Sagibgareev: интервью
Игорь А.: ну да да ну и то есть ему плюс что его пропиарили он
Maxim Sagibgareev: дал и им Найди этот сайт. Я
Игорь А.: найду.
Maxim Sagibgareev: А тут,
Игорь А.: получается, мы можем идти к ним и говорить,
Maxim Sagibgareev: смотрите, мы можем вашу экспертизу продавать детям, помогать и так далее. И вы будете в свой дополнительный
Игорь А.: доход.
Maxim Sagibgareev: Есть в России
Игорь А.: такой сервис PressFit. Там тоже можно зарегистрироваться. Если ищут СМИ какого -то специалиста, то ты
Maxim Sagibgareev: можешь бесплатно там... Как называется? Пресс -фит.
Maxim Sagibgareev: Пресс -фит. Пресс -фит. А, пресс -фит. Скин тоже ссылку. Пресс -фит. Ну,
Maxim Sagibgareev: в принципе, быть в публичном пространстве неплохо. Многие, какие -то эксперты захотят публичности, но почему бы нет. У нас какое преимущество международное? Вот в чем я хочу вас...
Maxim Sagibgareev: Потому что все -таки международность, а не только Россия. Хотя мы все оттуда.
Maxim Sagibgareev: Я как бы не к тому, что мы локально убираем, а к тому, что международное у нас должно быть первым.
Maxim Sagibgareev: И вот он профиль у тебя эксперта, он внутри у нас партнер, у него там своя аудитория есть, плюс мы ему даем еще новую аудиторию, плюс потенциально какие -то фишки, соревнования или
Maxim Sagibgareev: еще что -то. Самый лучший эксперт в России, самый лучший эксперт мира. Чем -то еще можно придумывать. О, смотрите, час назад выложено. Современное школьное образование, МИР24.
Maxim Sagibgareev: условно говоря вот там миф -24 ищет эксперта по такой тематике узкие скинетут с подкой скинь тоже это прямо на главный час чтобы не потеряли мы потом она же уйдет
Maxim Sagibgareev: она не уйдет да вот я ссылку прям на сам запрос ответить на запрос журналиста можно ну
Maxim Sagibgareev: смотрите то есть вот представьте что Теперь кто задает вопросы, когда новичок? Новичок. Кто еще задает вопросы? Родители. А тут кто задает вопросы? Журналисты. Никакой
Игорь А.: разницы нет. То есть просто убираем журналистов, а у нас теперь задают вопросы, ну как бы, не вопросы,
Maxim Sagibgareev: а
Игорь А.: вот, ну, запрос на консультацию, или там запрос на
Maxim Sagibgareev: ну, как это назвать, на пробы, на эксперименты. Мы можем стандарт сделать один. Запрос на уроки.
Игорь А.: У тебя есть эксперты, есть разные запросы. есть автоматика есть не автоматика
Maxim Sagibgareev: он хочешь выбрал ск а уж и
Игорь А.: я вот такой -то эксперт
Maxim Sagibgareev: да вот хочу рассказать и там тоже твой профиль появляется и мы увидим слушал экспертиза нету в профиле чтобы ответить заполни профиль пошел заполнил профиль мы проверили потом можешь
Maxim Sagibgareev: отвечать то есть тут по всякому можно подойти я как бы не к тому что какой -то один правильный вариант есть просто хочется именно опять же мой аргумент сообщества сообщества и внутри
Maxim Sagibgareev: и формистские решения и в принципе у нас есть продукт и бесплатном
Игорь А.: виде люди же бесплатно магазины тоже ходят ничего не покупают и бесплатно там прикольно посмотреть там еще что -то
Maxim Sagibgareev: тут тоже он пришел посмотрел то
Игорь А.: есть какие запросы то но расскажите а какие вузы есть вообще
Maxim Sagibgareev: а есть что -то еще кроме вуза а А какие названия? А расскажите. А это какое? А это какое? Вот информационный просто запрос.
Maxim Sagibgareev: А профессии какие есть? Ну то есть у нас же это тоже может все быть.
Maxim Sagibgareev: Или вы говорите, что это не то? Или то?
Maxim Sagibgareev: Ну давай отмотаем, от чего пошла ветка текущего разговора. Она пошла от формирования пакетов. Правильно?
Maxim Sagibgareev: Ну если еще дальше, то вебинар и конверсия в продажу у эксперта, чтобы у эксперта что -то купили. Вот, сформировать эти пакеты, чтобы покупать у эксперта. Да.
Maxim Sagibgareev: Ну то есть экспертом же тоже должен быть повод там быть и как бы и другим заходить туда, то есть когда нету экспертов, мало экспертов. Ну понятно, что мало это просто небольшой клуб
Maxim Sagibgareev: у нас, назовем так, эволюция идет, постепенное развитие.
Maxim Sagibgareev: Можем пойти вот такими малыми рывками, то есть сейчас доделать это в виде клуба, но можем делать его незакрытым пока. мы
Maxim Sagibgareev: можем все равно говорить что подавайте заявку а там мы рассмотрим подавать заявку куда то чтобы стать экспертом клуба то есть получается две аудитории до станет спертом либо ты уже
Maxim Sagibgareev: как эксперт прокачать другие экспертизы смотри вот так еще может наверно прокачать экспертизу то может быть фундаментальным предметом вообще всей работы вот смотри когда ты игру какую
Maxim Sagibgareev: -то скачешь что внутри есть игра там какая -то механика пошла ты зашел в игру ты игрок кто -то создал эту игру да вот у вас связка случилось потом ты можешь играть в этой игре с кем
Maxim Sagibgareev: -то можешь играть сам и закончить
Вадим Х.: и
Maxim Sagibgareev: у нас получается что
Maxim Sagibgareev: единство всего здесь это это эксперт это экспертиза то есть это набор компетенции потому что всегда ими делишься у тебя есть набор компетенции которые даете результат и ты ими делишься
Maxim Sagibgareev: потом кто -то битая круче чем ты в твоей экспертизы и в результатах вот у меня какие факторы я измеряю почему я лучше
Maxim Sagibgareev: например но кто -то хочет пойдет к тому кто лучше но может быть дороже окей пойдет к другому который дешевле и
Вадим Х.: может быть чуть чуть хуже но
Maxim Sagibgareev: всем у всех есть место все могут быть я предлагаю за дичь и сделать у нас сегодня был очень важный разговор и чтобы запись там сильно не улетела потом ну вы здесь вообще не
Игорь А.: здесь не
Maxim Sagibgareev: нет тут ты же не говорим в раз ну
Maxim Sagibgareev: подскажи что ты хочешь чтобы она говрил у меня куча мыслей я предлагаю сделать запись на дальше я предлагаю смотрите как все что было сказано систематизировать найти здесь ключевое
Maxim Sagibgareev: ядро центр который есть вот всего что сказано потому что здесь многосторонний рынок есть нем ядро и вот в этом ядро нужно прям прям вот его прям вот чтобы там уже ничего туда не впихнуть
Maxim Sagibgareev: короче вот она описана про игры я сказал это игрок и игра сама а внутри есть игры сам игровой опыт вот у нас тоже самое есть какой -то сеанс или какой -то продукт внутри есть какой
Maxim Sagibgareev: -то опыт который происходит есть экспертиза ну как я это вижу и все и мы тогда теперь можем формировать обе стороны мы можем реестр делать все то есть что такое вузы набор экспертов
Maxim Sagibgareev: одном месте под одной организации вадима можешь
Вадим Х.: разошарить то что
Maxim Sagibgareev: мы с тобой по играм сделали ребята буквально на 5 минут давай им покажем сможешь или тебе неудобно ну если нет просто между включиться с телефона в этом парня может кто -то может заширить
Maxim Sagibgareev: я хочу скинуть
Александр Бондаренко: презентацию ну да запросов
Maxim Sagibgareev: кидай в чат на драктор давай это сми раскачаешься
Александр Бондаренко: вы
Maxim Sagibgareev: ребят ну сейчас кайфанете тоже мы вчера когда с водилом сидим и такие вадим вадим говорит так это же ко всему применимо
Maxim Sagibgareev: я думаю реально ко всему применим сейчас тормозить кинуть
Maxim Sagibgareev: мне давай кинуть да я захожу открываю долго все открылся так сейчас кидаю кому
Maxim Sagibgareev: куда скинуть в вотсап в telegram неудобно можешь нашу
Александр Бондаренко: общую группу скинуть туда в материалы и все увидят и откроют ну
Maxim Sagibgareev: контекста свожу то есть нам нужно продать услугу вот как раз таки такую индивидуальную супер дорогая который он говорил просто по сопровождению карьерному и там нужно было нужно показать
Maxim Sagibgareev: про всю карьеру чтобы чтобы родитель понимал что мы разбираемся вот мы сделали такое ну прям на данных нашли кучу данных там проанализировали всю экосистему сделали такой атлас экосистемный
Maxim Sagibgareev: вот так и называется вот и по сути вот как не знают спирт делаются также его выжим убрали все лишнее в эта версия первая но она уже прям хорошо получилось я бы еще чуть -чуть заработал
Maxim Sagibgareev: сейчас кидаю
Александр Бондаренко: вот
Maxim Sagibgareev: один вот еще прикольно может им отправить тоже steam с тем чтобы давать им тоже скинем как о версии
Maxim Sagibgareev: ну ладно не буду вас грузить пока данную вот открывать это что да видно потом например вот такая еще классная тема это проиграю давай проведи поэт сейчас сейчас секундочку он
Maxim Sagibgareev: саган
Maxim Sagibgareev: она я выщерка еще скинул пусть это будет вот такая еще 110 чтобы понимали куда как потом можно показывать это все вот но это не закончено пока не берите короче смотрите открывайте атлас
Maxim Sagibgareev: уже открыли мне нужно перезайти ребят сейчас секунду
Maxim Sagibgareev: так все сейчас будет если
Maxim Sagibgareev: ну всем видно можно приблизить чуть -чуть то есть смотри как бы у нас что происходит у нас есть какая -то игра есть играющий в игре есть правило есть определенный мир какие -то действия
Maxim Sagibgareev: и когда играющий играет он получает опыт то есть он что -то осваивает какое -то соревнование эмоции возникают у него он понимает смысл этого всего ну и потенциально общается какая -то
Maxim Sagibgareev: коммуникации есть если это социальная игра вот человек и общество общество какое -то она играет в эту игру 0 3 вот
Maxim Sagibgareev: и даже
Maxim Sagibgareev: не так смотрите то есть в эту игру надо еще попасть чтобы не попасть тебе нужен доступ то есть чтоб тебе в этот сеанс игры попасть или там вот не важно берите любую игру теннис физический
Maxim Sagibgareev: теннис любую игру берите тебе нужен доступ и инфраструктура если это цифровая игра то тебе нужен цифровой доступ какое -то устройство где -то должен ну там стартануть этот запуск случится
Maxim Sagibgareev: как ты должен это получить через магазин или какой -то прямой канал ну тоже должен скачать это получить я должен дать право все билетик у тебя куплен куплен зашел платеж есть есть там
Maxim Sagibgareev: доставка серверы одна компания может выполнить несколько ролей ну то есть поняли до доступ к игре окей инфраструктура потом кто -то должен заплатить чтобы туда попасть что получить
Maxim Sagibgareev: доступ и у как -то узнать оценить получить доступ начать играть а потом решить продолжать играть ну если он уже играет блин еще хочу играть потом вернуться играть там баскетбол в теннис
Maxim Sagibgareev: настольный теннис неважно в компьютерную игру какую -то либо завершить все завершил здесь мой как бы опыт закончился даже возвращаться не хочу как бы я все наполнился насытился может
Maxim Sagibgareev: быть такой вариант либо полностью идти и общая да вот потом потенциально обсудить это с кем -то либо там пригласить друзей либо еще кого -то и ну родители обычно бывают покупателями
Maxim Sagibgareev: игрок может различаться вот я там заплатил близкие они там не занимаются ну как игры и сеансы занятий по танцам похоже на игру принципе все тоже самое вот должна быть среда ну
Maxim Sagibgareev: как бы человек же должен об этом узнать то есть у тебя есть среда выбора и у тебя куча куча альтернатив есть черти делать какие занятия какие игры ведь занятия принципе все подходит
Maxim Sagibgareev: у нас тоже все занять сеанс консультации это занятие потом она так по деньгам доступно и доступно в по времени доступно недоступно и вот разные аудитории разные потребности разные ситуации
Maxim Sagibgareev: окей теперь ну как бы с этой стороны все поняли теперь идем 0405 производство предложения кто -то должен это произвести все они создают они происследовали рынок придумали концепт потом
Maxim Sagibgareev: своем мануальный прототип выпустил посмотрели как он там работает и занимается поддержкой теперь готового продукта и выпускает новые продукты потенциально вот и мы как команда обещаем
Maxim Sagibgareev: какой -то опыт даем какие -то условия и говорим что вот это все будет у нас вот мы так это создадим для этого нам нужно создать или организация это авторы соавторы когда внутренняя
Александр Бондаренко: команда внешняя команда
Maxim Sagibgareev: и у нас есть проект проект формирует какую -то конкретную игру ну какой -то продукт давайте так вот
Александр Бондаренко: и мы можем вести много
Maxim Sagibgareev: разных продуктов параллельно есть партнеры и финансирование издатель инвестор правообладатель сервисы деньги права все это отдельная история но по сути вот человек поиграл у него какие
Maxim Sagibgareev: -то сигналы пошли это 0708 наблюдение и обучения но там какие -то действия платежи может быть моему тесты какие -то сдали он там к сд в какой -то воздухе собрали какие -то у нас ограничения
Maxim Sagibgareev: есть ну мы какую -то картинку собираем это по сути свидетельство который нам помогает улучшать нашу игру и предложение план ну и так далее и это все информирует уже юка экономику и
Maxim Sagibgareev: формирует производство а экономика по сути устроена как выручка доля получателя какой -то вклад и вот он результат проекта
Maxim Sagibgareev: вот можем дальше идти
Maxim Sagibgareev: ну то есть то есть вот тут кстати тоже прикольно потому что есть устройство это вот ну вообще вопрос охрененно здесь написаны не прям стало все понятно на чем человек видит игру и управляет
Maxim Sagibgareev: ею ну вот писи консоль я бы еще физический мир здесь бы еще добавил как то вот следующую версию этой всей истории чтобы тоже было понятно
Игорь А.: среда исполнения вот
Maxim Sagibgareev: они вот она среда исполнения linux кстати тоже добавил здесь консольная среда браузер удаленный компьютер а
Александр Бондаренко: ну да ударенный компьютер
Maxim Sagibgareev: магазин где -то это все купишь право
Maxim Sagibgareev: доступа что -то купил лицензию купил или там бесплатно вообще доступ скачал просто и заходишь регистрация нужно либо это подписка идет потом как тебе эта игра попадет ты это скачал
Maxim Sagibgareev: либо это но физический носитель что -то диски раньше были да или какая -то игра вот настолько физическая веб -доступ у тебя может быть видео поток он тоже популярно многие же не имеют
Maxim Sagibgareev: крутых машинах хотят играть в игры они заходят платят
Maxim Sagibgareev: способ оплаты независимо от способа запуска потом сетевая инфраструктура как игра это вообще где она работает и продажи расчеты то есть через что было там это все сделано и вот у тебя
Maxim Sagibgareev: получается смотрите мы все время идем к одному событию у всех студий у всех агентств одно желание чтобы человек играл
Maxim Sagibgareev: и вот внизу рада пути то есть на пока вот как ты играешь ты зашел в steam купил лицензию загрузил на локальный комп запустил играешь в консоли например зашел магаз купил консоль там
Maxim Sagibgareev: право доступа подписка не задам пас какой то есть на playstation там еще что туда вот все запустил играешь смартфон тоже самое в магазин установил Бесплатный вход или покупка играешь.
Maxim Sagibgareev: В браузере ссылку нажал, страница открылась, запустил, без установки играешь. В облаке то же самое. Каталог выбрал в каталоге, подписку сделал. Удаленный запуск случился, тебе видеопоток,
Maxim Sagibgareev: ты играешь.
Maxim Sagibgareev: Идем дальше. Но по факту человек играет. Вот TPI какой, он играет. Ну, еще, наверное, ему нравится. Как бы это тоже важная история. Ну, не знаю, некоторые выбирают хардкор режим, и
Maxim Sagibgareev: им не нравится. но они все равно играют им нравится ну ну ну хорошо да то есть я думаю все нравится то что им не нравится но окей вот теперь на
Александр Бондаренко: кратер но не получают
Maxim Sagibgareev: до получают опыт игрока начинается до запуска и продолжается после него то
Maxim Sagibgareev: есть опыт нашего клиента и внутри игры основной цикл есть и вот первый пошло узнать об игре там друг рассказал тебе сам автор видео поделился реклама какая -то была в поиске нашел витрину
Maxim Sagibgareev: увидел события какое -то было он об этом узнал вот и порядок может меняться видите внизу написано то есть подарок подписка тесты приглашение позволяет пропустить части шагов можно все
Maxim Sagibgareev: перепрыгнуть потом ты оцениваешь ok прикольное обещание классный жанр там интересные сцены цена мне тоже нравится отзывы прикольные да и вообще мне это все моя любимая тема и вот сверху
Maxim Sagibgareev: аудитории это возможные участники игроки это те кто играют сообщества это все кто там взаимодействует между людьми все я останула теперь хочу доступ ну окей я купил подписка тоже самое
Maxim Sagibgareev: купил бесплатно зашел ну там будет реклама какая -то тоже тоже нажму и что -то започу все запустил освоился чё за цель так как я как здесь вообще этот юай пользоваться как и вот как
Maxim Sagibgareev: у нас там мы папе моему показали он докуплен где эта кнопка все потерялась что сделать куда идти вот понять цель управления смысл действий пройти первые препятствия вот все прошло первые
Maxim Sagibgareev: препятствия у тебя тут пошли
Александр Бондаренко: внутри игры ключевой цикл заместил
Maxim Sagibgareev: игрока что я хочу сделать действия
Александр Бондаренко: какой выбор и делаю я так это делаю
Maxim Sagibgareev: вот как
Александр Бондаренко: система отвечает прикольно блин
Maxim Sagibgareev: прикольно а что дальше все я дальше иду или там я дальше хожу или там я дальше не знаю вожу мышкой или еще что -то а дальше хочу сделать так как я это делаю прикольно что дальше там
Maxim Sagibgareev: победить кого -то там уроны нанести не знаю шаг поставить мячик кинуть
Maxim Sagibgareev: переложить эти цветные кубики разные игры бывают ну или вот то же самое в теннис ты играешь сам так чем не отбить надо отбить на доке моё действие отбиваю ok а мне обратно прилетает
Maxim Sagibgareev: окей на что делать дальше блин упала все чему научился не должно падать окей что дальше опять кидаю опять отбиваю теперь уже вот то есть получается то что тут неважно вообще про какую
Maxim Sagibgareev: игру мы говорим и не только про игру
Александр Бондаренко: потом идет следующее
Maxim Sagibgareev: действие
Александр Бондаренко: бы
Maxim Sagibgareev: продолжить мне надо ну то есть качество переживания видите высшие социальный контекст тоже они как бы параллельно они иногда бывает что нету социального контекста ты один делаешь счету
Maxim Sagibgareev: с друзьями или незнакомыми и тут у тебя либо сотрудничество либо конкуренция ну и важно без безопасности модерации это со стороны
Александр Бондаренко: платформы чтобы все было хорошо качество переживаний тоже понятно снова как ты говоришь не только позитивные эмоции
Maxim Sagibgareev: ну там без тебя все ты тоже доволен этим преодолел там выиграл мосты всякие ты управляешься смысле там выбор темп свой доступность подходящая техническая надежность открывается ну как
Maxim Sagibgareev: бы все работает какие варианты после вот и поиграл ты можешь продолжить то есть вот я сейчас первый цикл закончился основной ну иди еще раз в этот цикл там в игре же у тебя получается
Maxim Sagibgareev: два цикла один ключевой внутри то есть по сути любая игра это две игры в общая игра и потом микроигры всякие разные мы тут с вами тоже общались ну это то же самое что фичи у тебя есть
Maxim Sagibgareev: ты можешь тест сделать ты можешь там добавить семью это все микроигры внутри приложения которые ты делаешь у них свои результаты свои задачи про влечить шанер не любая что еще раз играет
Maxim Sagibgareev: и прошел все никаких микро у тебя не любая игра и говоришь в целом ну скорее всего да наверное не любая если ты ну я просто к чему не важно не тут как бы такой момент то что когда ты
Maxim Sagibgareev: играешь в любую игру ты можешь разделить на начало середина игры конец игры вот это могут быть разные задачи то есть том же сам теннис и тебе вначале надо подачу сделать это микроигра
Maxim Sagibgareev: сделать подачу потом тебе нужно отбить это другая игра
Maxim Sagibgareev: микро игра внутри игры поэтому в такой вот я про такую парадигму говорю не говорю что ты там играл в теннис потом все в шахматы на счет то
Maxim Sagibgareev: есть всегда есть микроигра навсегда это по сути ну как бы действия которые ты улучшаешь это как какая -то микро композиция навыка задачи на маленький ну да так она в любой игре есть
Maxim Sagibgareev: любой я всегда есть микроигра я не знаю хорошо приведи какой -то пример где ее нету
Maxim Sagibgareev: одного действия даже крестки ну может быть крестик и нолики ну да наверно крестик и но не может конечно всегда всегда можно разбить большую на маленькие какие -то это понятно вот
Maxim Sagibgareev: ну то есть можно продолжить вернуться позже пройти снова закончить с удовольствием или нет уйти видите из -за проблемы какой -то но уход у тебя всегда может быть по разным причинам
Maxim Sagibgareev: так что еще что человек уносит ну вот он получил опыт там прикольно все впечатление историю всяким потом как он возвращается систему мы видим отзывы мы видим аналитику всю
Maxim Sagibgareev: приглашение еще что он сделал вот а мы каком она проверяем и смотрим наблюдаем какие события были в игре поняли какие причины все -таки он ушел или остался ведь и сыграл понял получил
Maxim Sagibgareev: обещанное готов вернуться ли рекомендовать типа разные вещи
Maxim Sagibgareev: сыграл понял но не получил то что обещали сыграл не понял и не получил что вы еще или сыграл не понял но получил что обещали сыграл готов вернуться сыграл готов вернуться он рекомендовать
Maxim Sagibgareev: них не готов не рекомендуешь вообще никогда ничего то есть как бы тут все может быть в плане человека ok идем дальше его
Maxim Sagibgareev: тут тоже прикольно то что ну как бы кто -то придумал эту игру и
Maxim Sagibgareev: чтобы ну те придумать это одна компетенция потом ее надо воплотить есть как бы разные функции роли человека вот сам человек это носитель компетенции командно совместная работа рган
Maxim Sagibgareev: компания от организация прав и обязательств
Maxim Sagibgareev: вот прям вот хорошая четкое определение всего вообще любой команды любой у любого человека авторы соавтора ведь формулирует он творческое намерение и так далее там обещание делать принципы
Maxim Sagibgareev: делают вот потом это могут быть разные люди проектная команда там уже дальше идет конкретным результатом мои партнеры владеют тогда и компетенции смотрите игровой дизайн то есть правило
Maxim Sagibgareev: собрать баланс сделать структуру сделать потом технология чтобы работающего была сборка разные слои пошли контент и подача производства и качества выход к аудитории бизнес и поддержка
Maxim Sagibgareev: вот концепт Кому и зачем? Прототип работает ли опыт? Средс качества можем ли мы произвести? Выпуск готова ли игра и доступ? Есть ли смысл продолжать? Ну тут риски всякие, способности
Maxim Sagibgareev: есть. Окей, давайте дальше.
Maxim Sagibgareev: Вот он спрос, как он проверяется.
Maxim Sagibgareev: Понятно ли обещание, вот то, что вы докручиваете. Потом, есть ли работающий опыт? Прототип. Это вот сейчас в этом вебинар закидываем уже. Смотрим, окей. Совпадает ли ожидание с игрой?
Maxim Sagibgareev: ну
Maxim Sagibgareev: и вот конце ведь какое решение то есть уточнить аудиторию подачу ok стали у нас аудитория то а века должен быть или не века ну не века давайте попробуем вебинар веке вебинар агурас
Maxim Sagibgareev: цикл ну цикл вот такой то вначале должен быть прототип ой не прототип говорю бесплатный скрининг потом тест потом уже там
Александр Бондаренко: следующем профориентация
Maxim Sagibgareev: а давайте поменяем давайте начале будет вид магнит потом вебинар а потом уже на вебинаре будет линейка вариантов
Александр Бондаренко: привлекательные условия как раз таки вот
Maxim Sagibgareev: тут мы их обсуждаем это же вы их тестируете работает для продвижения вот мы сейчас с этим и занимаемся и
Maxim Sagibgareev: по сути одна матрица по всем рынкам может быть к аудитория какое -то обещание даешь коммерческое
Александр Бондаренко: предложение как нему ты приходишь
Maxim Sagibgareev: вот механика там лично мы встретились или ты через my next .com зашел там еще чего -то да какая цена какая платформа сколько лет твоему предложению уже сколько она на рынке есть какие
Maxim Sagibgareev: ресурсы у вас есть
Александр Бондаренко: сопоставляем успешные слабые
Maxim Sagibgareev: незавершенные всякие
Александр Бондаренко: проекты есть наблюдение и можем понять а мы конкурентны в этом рынке не конкурентно в этом рынке так идем дальше ну
Александр Бондаренко: экономика конверсии но это ваша любимая то есть игра может стоить 20 баксов то есть важно кто платит за что платят и кому принадлежит
Maxim Sagibgareev: результат да то есть эти все факторы важны и поэтому
Александр Бондаренко: условный пример да то есть игрок пришел там это игрок платит есть рекламодатель бесплатная игра кликнул на рекламу рекламодатель запустил там подписка тоже игрок платит ну и так далее
Александр Бондаренко: в общем 20 долларов мы заплатили после скидки уже после скидки
Александр Бондаренко: налог взяли за
Maxim Sagibgareev: канал заплатили то что конверсия есть за рекламу заплатили мы получили 8 баксов в конце продали за 20 и теперь сколько мы таких сделали покупок ну то есть это тираж. Сколько было продано
Maxim Sagibgareev: таких итераций? Мы умножаем на вклад.
Maxim Sagibgareev: И вот она прибыль, условно. Зная затраты в месяц, зная вклад после рекламы и зная количество проданного в тираже, вот мы с вами делаем. Проходим мы порог выживания или не проходим?
Александр Бондаренко: В
Maxim Sagibgareev: играх, кстати, очень много
Александр Бондаренко: платят за дополнения в DLC. Во многих играх дел с и больше чем первая продажа в базовая игра ведь первая продаж ты
Maxim Sagibgareev: попадется заполнение там ну бывает одинаково будет одинаково да вот предметы продажа равна нулю и хватит только заделся бывает что первая продажа 0 не делать и уже ты можешь игры делать
Maxim Sagibgareev: это как бы дальше на следующая версия
Maxim Sagibgareev: вроде другая другой типа это не внутри гастровы
Александр Бондаренко: бывает
Maxim Sagibgareev: разное вот знаете вот часто как бывает игру прошел а через там три месяца или через полгода выходит делся и это типа такое ответвление основной компании типа а что было с адамом джексоном
Maxim Sagibgareev: пока он ехал
Александр Бондаренко: из гонку из детройда в гонконг он был на корабле и типа это вот просто как отдельно такая большая миссия
Maxim Sagibgareev: который в принципе могли бы со своим сюжетом просто дополнительно который какую -то историю там дополнительную расширяющую рассказывает бывает вот так а бывает вот вроде бы вот я знаю
Maxim Sagibgareev: atomic her там вроде бы как отдельно просто там вот как я не взять на там из игры как -то там искать эту как бы миссию там просто ты там играть играть как у тебя такой топник такая
Maxim Sagibgareev: тоже какая -то отдельная история ну что неправильно водной базе какой -то
Александр Бондаренко: там они были да
Maxim Sagibgareev: да да за правильно говоришь вот потом за что еще платят какие -то предметы внутри ну там counter -strike там еще по боксу как отразится за всякие эти микротрансакции валюта какая -то
Maxim Sagibgareev: внутреннее может быть потом сезонные тоже есть истории ты подписку делаешь сезонную сама подписка просто какая -то реклама еще что -то вот ну кому это принадлежит там проекту студию
Maxim Sagibgareev: издатель инвестору и так далее то есть издательский аванс Вот тут написано, это про игры говорится. То есть это друг, как бы, ну, справа. Ну, это понятно так.
Maxim Sagibgareev: Так, учебное допущение. Есть кей -то плей, да, вот. Бесплатный вход не означает отсутствие выручки. Это вот кей -то плей -модель, особенно вот онлайновая. И ты просто скачиваешь игру,
Maxim Sagibgareev: играешь, и такой, купи премиум аккаунт. И будет падать больше опыта. Ну, я почему вам это все показываю? Я хочу, чтобы мы с вами делали нашу платформу игры. Это наша игра. вот так же
Maxim Sagibgareev: подошли к ней вот все что вы сейчас делаете то есть это не игра как игра
Александр Бондаренко: а прикольный
Maxim Sagibgareev: сервис или платформа как игра но игра ну как бы платформа
Александр Бондаренко: сама для реальной жизни для
Maxim Sagibgareev: решения задачи проблем реальной жизни мне нравится этот подход не знаю почему -то у меня импонирует и он ну когда ты понимаешь границы когда у тебя есть упаковка когда у тебя структура
Maxim Sagibgareev: как бы конкурировать с рынком тоже становится легче мне стало более понятно а как бы ты описал подход то есть когда есть какая -то описанная визуальная модель того что и как нужно делать
Maxim Sagibgareev: для полной картины ну это называется экосистему видишь то есть атлас и
Александр Бондаренко: карта у тебя есть и у тебя есть ну терминология какая здесь используется то есть все понятно вот и это больше но это конкретно про игры видеоигры больше даже про видеоигры если еще
Александр Бондаренко: сделать один раунд как бы адаптации этого документа то можно сделать и про физические игры окей а потом еще один раунд адаптации и не просто про игры а про занятия шире чем игры и мы
Александр Бондаренко: все чем -то занимаемся и вот мы помогаем другим заниматься любимым делом зарабатывать деньги а
Maxim Sagibgareev: другим помогаем либо видишь школе какой -то там
Александр Бондаренко: либо в
Maxim Sagibgareev: университете ну как
Александр Бондаренко: бы когда мы отправляем кого -то в институт по сути мы продаем этот институт в институте есть всякие эксперты которых есть экспертиза которые хотят этим делиться и зарабатывать на этим
Александр Бондаренко: деньги то есть как бы но это платформенный же подход то есть ты связываешь ты делаешь осуществляет чтобы транзакция случилась и нам платят по сути за что нам платят за вход за подписку
Александр Бондаренко: и нам вкладят микротранзакции внутри ну вот пакет у нас там то есть пакеты оплатили
Maxim Sagibgareev: какие -то услуги заплатили за рекламу рекламу нас на никакой нету она реклама это
Александр Бондаренко: когда мы кому -то кого -то другого продаем но
Maxim Sagibgareev: это все равно наш внутренний
Александр Бондаренко: услуг они у нас микротранзакции и чисто воды вот смотри
Maxim Sagibgareev: ну сообщество есть есть
Maxim Sagibgareev: запись идет нормально все или у нас бил
Александр Бондаренко: сбилась все в порядке ну может это еще пишет
Александр Бондаренко: у меня почему мне нравится не просто в целом я с вами как бы открыто говорю тут нет какого такого как игра просто вроде как приколы все блин играем вот есть люди
Maxim Sagibgareev: которые разрабатывают игры причем
Александр Бондаренко: я посмотрел сейчас и просто охерел дэн -дэн -2 кто -то видел да это как так можно придумать вообще как это сделали игра эта система вообще как это как газпром приду сделать вот
Maxim Sagibgareev: ну
Александр Бондаренко: то есть вот какая такая история
Maxim Sagibgareev: и вот у нас получается своя ниша то есть по развитию по
Александр Бондаренко: обучению и вот куда
Maxim Sagibgareev: ты попадаешь ты попадаешь на платформу а тот что ну тут все про твое развитие смысле ну
Александр Бондаренко: вот пиши что ты хочешь ну я там думаю про это вот мы родители мы что -то не знаем окей добавлять со детей
Maxim Sagibgareev: добавили и вот он пошел типа цикл игровой игровой цикл мы тебя он
Александр Бондаренко: бординг сделали рассказали вот как красиво все смотри у нас
Maxim Sagibgareev: свой свой мир ну как apple сделали просто железку продаю за 2000 баксов но смотрите
Игорь А.: вот как на как наложить
Maxim Sagibgareev: вот у нас аудитория
Игорь А.: родители для родителей важно доверие для родителей важно экспертность для родителей важны результаты вот у нас сейчас такой вот крупный камень который у нас вот объективно хромает и
Игорь А.: он сложно идет очень мотива важен это про то как нам людям
Maxim Sagibgareev: показывать свою экспертность не так что ну точнее так как показывает свою экспертность
Игорь А.: сразу многим людям и ну как бы массово то есть должны быть какие -то экспертные материалы и то есть нам нужно как вариант как вариант что еще нужно что еще ну сейчас я вот эту тему
Игорь А.: добьет давай просто это важно потому что нам нужно как -то научиться упаковывать свою экспертность какие -то полезные материалы которые вот но их ограниченное количество нам не нужно
Игорь А.: делать там 500 тысяч материалов нам нужно просто вот каких -то 35 единиц очень показательных качественных
Maxim Sagibgareev: важных материалов для аудитории которые нам может быть и год вперед они
Игорь А.: будут и два года вперед они будут вот просто ну актуальны для нашей аудитории нам нужно просто и сделать очень качестве виде примеры просто чтобы мы конкретики задачи ушли сейчас идеальный
Игорь А.: ключевой результат какой вот
Игорь А.: вот вот вот
Игорь А.: чек
Игорь А.: -лист 7 ошибок из -за которых дети теряют годы при поступлении как
Игорь А.: вариант один людям интересно они оставляют но вот говорю третий день уже пошел как я делаю на нейрон как но мне не получается супер чтобы это
Maxim Sagibgareev: было знаете как от руки сделанный материал который ты прочитал ты понял что делали эксперты делали
Игорь А.: научно они
Maxim Sagibgareev: писал оконченная нейронка у
Maxim Sagibgareev: нас очень важно то есть это как по сути первое касание мы бесплатно даем кусочек какой -то нашей там насмотренности экспертности то есть если вы сделать качественно вот пожалуйста люди
Maxim Sagibgareev: один видит качестве материал потом 2 мы сделаем материал допустим там топ профессии например которые там не не устареет ближайшее количество лет слышно слышно сейчас
Игорь А.: вышло это как демо версия которую не стыдно показать именно так вот именно так они еще не заплатили они заплатили своим контактом они перелись своим контактам хорошо кидая ее нам мы
Игорь А.: с вадимом добьем тебя что еще нужно пока что давайте с этого вот пока пока что вот это
Игорь А.: мы не в следующем это вебинар то есть а можно еще саш вот мы же вчера не общались с человеком по youtube у будет продолжение этого всего мне кажется что эту тему тоже как раз актуально
Игорь А.: поднять в формате вот ты как раз показываешь чек -лист для меня идеальный чек -лист это в котором есть файл и в котором есть видео объяснение к этому чек -листу это вообще может быть
Игорь А.: дальше Ну, это прям совсем идеально. Конечно, я бы хотел, чтобы еще и такой
Maxim Sagibgareev: результат.
Игорь А.: Нет, мы же и говорим про идеальный конечный результат. И вот я его
Maxim Sagibgareev: как раз дополняю, что для меня не
Игорь А.: просто файл, который пришел, а еще и вот говорящая голова, которая объясняет методологически и зачем, вот это вот большое зачем, ну, может
Maxim Sagibgareev: быть, небольшое зачем, Ну просто вот, что
Игорь А.: получит человек, заполнив для себя этот чек -лист? То есть какие у него дальнейшие ожидания от этого всего, какие шаги, что ему даст это все? Вот он открыл, о, классный чек -лист, это
Игорь А.: одно дело. Другое дело, он действительно проработал этот чек -лист.
Maxim Sagibgareev: А чек -лист -то зачем? Какой результат мы хотим? Чек -лист же способ? Да, смотри, что такое чек -лист. Вот Саша делает хорошие чек -листы, мы обсуждали это все дело.
Игорь А.: Чек -лист, вот есть, например, у нас некий процесс. Процесс вот с точки, в которой находится абитуриент в данный момент, до
Maxim Sagibgareev: счастливая работа, которая приносит удовольствие и деньги. И вот чек -лист это разбитый процесс на подпроцессы, который отвечает за какой -то из этих подпроцессов
Игорь А.: и дает ответ как. То есть что сделать и как на каком -то из этапов. То есть вот чек -лист – это как
Maxim Sagibgareev: раз -таки не полный процесс описанный, а описанный маленький один из подпроцессов, который действительно, если применить, то можно закрыть одну из задач, которая стоит на пути от точки
Maxim Sagibgareev: А к точки Б.
Maxim Sagibgareev: Ну, какую -то горячую первичную задачу закрыть. Да.
Maxim Sagibgareev: Услышал. Вы говорите, какой это материал. Давайте еще хотя бы 2 -3 варианта, какой материал еще нужен. насчет этого я понял его задача понятно чтобы по сути мы показали что смотри игрок
Maxim Sagibgareev: ты принял ты умеешь играть там во всякие игры а вот тебе смотри какая новая игра крутая у нас есть вот короткая просто посмотри немножко ты
Александр Бондаренко: же любишь играть футуристические игры
Maxim Sagibgareev: про будущее вот
Александр Бондаренко: тебе про меня по -другому
Maxim Sagibgareev: немножко подошел бы к этому
Александр Бондаренко: концепту вот в играх есть перки то есть это некие Древо навыков, которые, если ты прокачиваешь одним или другим способом, тебе открываются другие навыки. И вот представь, что есть большое
Александр Бондаренко: древо. И условно говоря, открываешь первый шажок, тебе раз, три на выбор. Чтобы все три открыть, ты все три никогда не прокачаешь. Это вот про экспертизу, про пути, которые ты никогда
Александр Бондаренко: не пройдешь. Скорее всего, у тебя есть ограничения игры. Но если ты выбираешь там один или два пути, по крайней мере, их пересечения какие -то, они будут давать тебе
Игорь А.: нужные навыки. То есть ты должен вообще как бы вот эту цель понять, конечно, кем ты хочешь быть,
Александр Бондаренко: лучником, магом и так далее. То есть какие -то навыки, которые у тебя магом, каким там, древесным, огненным, холод, неважно. А кто еще есть? Кто еще есть? Лучники, маги, кто еще? Да
Александр Бондаренко: там условно варвар. Нет, перечисляй всех. Хорошо, смотря в какой мы вселенной. Окей, некромант, варвар, ассасин, гномы, эльфы, темные эльфы. Кто еще?
Александр Бондаренко: Ну тут, ребят, вы уже можете... Саш, помогай. Хорошо, там даже по оружию можно, там луки, арбалеты, автоматы, пистолеты, гранатометы.
Maxim Sagibgareev: ручное оружие метательное оружие лучники лучники магии друиды кто там еще были подождите сейчас микромант ассасин варвар варвар варвар точно до паладин
Александр Бондаренко: до друид ты уже назвал о чем вы вообще говорите мы говорим про карьеру будущее когда
Maxim Sagibgareev: будет и у нас останутся только друиды
Игорь А.: барбары
Игорь А.: психологи надо я соседу я говорю про систему прокачивания о том что она не линейная то есть нет это я понял хотел слышал вот смотрите а теперь представьте что мы сейчас упаковываем
Игорь А.: игру вот для
Maxim Sagibgareev: упаковки
Игорь А.: игры нужен материал чтобы но я вот например как сам моя конверсия там зашел в youtube потом какой -то чувак играет в группе прикольную смешную это клуба нифига себе классно и пошел
Игорь А.: скачал ее и поиграл
Игорь А.: вот и вы же простите говорите про тоже про какую -то конверсию чтобы потом человек пришел получил опыт с нами внутри нашей игры вот какой материал вам нужен еще то насчет чек -листов
Игорь А.: но это по сути практичная статья конкретная инструкция к действию до
Игорь А.: мое мнение такое видео выскали видео какой -то вот вот вот первый шаг типа а3 вот таких каких -то текстовых материалов pdf и которые можно скачать а дальше просто вот контент и фактура
Игорь А.: для видео то
Maxim Sagibgareev: есть чтобы системно
Игорь А.: генерить контент удачу уже просто следующий этап вот игорь ты говоришь вот мы да у нас понедельник был созвон от чуваком по ютюбу чувак по ютюбу такой вот я стратег вот меня там стоит
Игорь А.: под ключ типа вот вести вот такой канал где -то там от 100 до 150 бюджет в
Maxim Sagibgareev: месяц и но я сразу голове понимаю 150 он сказал примерно до
Игорь А.: типа он за 80 вот у него типа как как он работает по 8000 платим он делает как аудит
Maxim Sagibgareev: стратегию и точный делает
Игорь А.: просчет бюджета более точный сколько примерно из контента сколько месяц надо будет чего делать и то есть из этого уже это месячный бюджет.
Maxim Sagibgareev: Я как бы понимаю, мы
Игорь А.: сейчас, даже если мы ему завтра заплатим 8 тысяч, а потом заплатим там, не знаю, 203 тысячи, мы эффективно этот канал не сможем использовать,
Maxim Sagibgareev: потому что... как бы
Игорь А.: нам нужно какой -то как -то системно выдавать контент который полезен целевой аудитории то
Maxim Sagibgareev: есть дай мне
Игорь А.: дай мне такой нормальный
Maxim Sagibgareev: минимальный
Игорь А.: минимум системно да вижу игорь спасибо системно выдавать это сколько штук месяц и чего ну плюс -минус плюс -минус хотя
Игорь А.: Ну, если, допустим, хотя бы там по две сторис в неделю. Давай я так накину,
Александр Бондаренко: Саша. Можно я возьму слово? Давай. Смотри. То есть, что я услышал от него, и это имеет ядро хорошее. Он говорит, есть две стратегии, условно говоря, набора подписчиков и просмотров.
Александр Бондаренко: Первое – это горизонтальное видео, когда мы делаем большие длинные видео. И второе это шортсы, то есть это когда мы целенаправленно пишем конкретно шортсы под короткие видео. И соответственно
Александр Бондаренко: говорит, я пока не могу сказать, что нужно вам, потому что это отдельная оплата и так далее. Но учитывая то, что вы там даже этот нейрослоп нагенерили и он там дал какие -то там под
Александр Бондаренко: 7000 просмотров, понятное дело, что этот формат зайдет однозначно. Вот,
Maxim Sagibgareev: но по поводу горизонтальных видео это нужно там смотреть и просчитывать. Так вот, если говорить про, условно говоря, количество единиц
Александр Бондаренко: шорцев, их там можно 2 -3 в день выкладывать и можно по одному выкладывать. То есть минимум это там 7, максимум это 21 в неделю. Если говорить про видео, это там 2 видео максимум. Может
Александр Бондаренко: быть даже поначалу 2 -3, потом можно к одному перейти в видео со временем, месяца через 3. То есть количество единиц контента выпускать меньше. Больше вначале, чтобы попасть в целевую
Александр Бондаренко: аудиторию и понять их отклик и вообще на что они реагируют. И как только мы попадаем, условно говоря, это я уже от себя, как только мы попадаем в целевую аудиторию, где мы там набрали
Александр Бондаренко: сотни тысяч, миллион просмотров, мы просто вот эту тему начинаем долбить. Вот такая стратегия всегда. То есть, правильно я понимаю, что все вот эти вот истории с шортсами, это пилотник,
Александр Бондаренко: чтобы понять ядро глобальной аудитории, типа такого? Не всегда. Смотри, это стратегия более быстрого набора количества просмотров. Она же дает и подписки. Ну, что?
Maxim Sagibgareev: вот
Александр Бондаренко: как раз таки про цель смотри даже вот этот нейрослоп он дал там сколько 2 реги или сколько саш на скрининге то есть даже вот это действие которое запустилось автоматически там что -то
Александр Бондаренко: делалось условно бесплатная она дала там 2 реги неважно мы все равно делая какое -то действие должны подразумевать куда мы хотим привести это может быть как раз таки например вебинар
Александр Бондаренко: это может быть там какой -нибудь скрининг да то есть мы можем регулировать конечное действие то есть например мы хотим ему сказать смотри наша цель чтобы продавалась 50 профориентаций
Александр Бондаренко: по 20000 то есть мы хотим миллион с этого вот мы 200 тысяч вкладываем и хотим миллион все продумывая стратегии что нужно между вот этими двумя опять же . и . и б вот шорцы ok шорцы
Александр Бондаренко: длинные горизонтальные океи горизонтальные ну вот цель вот такая и чтобы это было вот мое мнение нам нужно какую -то сделать систему и вы там не за может быть базу знаний наполняем
Александр Бондаренко: вот тема раскрытие темы тема раскрыть этими поль типа не знаю как выбрать вуз раскрытие темы на хрена
Maxim Sagibgareev: тебе выбирать вуз ты не знаешь критерия не своей там личности не то что тебе подойдет не профессии иди там на брук
Александр Бондаренко: ориентации все тему раскрыли в каком -то виде там 357 абзацев все из этого уже можно сделать рим из этого можно сделать видео из этого можно использовать там не знает креатива где -то
Александр Бондаренко: ну то есть вот короче фактура наверное это все то есть здесь по сути для того чтобы пилить видео нужно чтобы был по сути огромный пласт знаний про более именно и оплат знаний не такой
Александр Бондаренко: который на генерит нейрон к а вот знаешь как вот я не знаю как описать то с чем мы сталкиваемся каждый день у клиентов на чем они совершают ошибки чего необычно не знаю что необычно
Александр Бондаренко: делать неправильно где они теряют деньги где они теряют время что они вот мы им объясняем они в упор не понимают
Maxim Sagibgareev: вы представляете
Александр Бондаренко: мы говорим у каждый раз они всегда этого не делают в прикиньте тема раскрытия темы ну то есть я не знаю вот как какой -то издательство
Maxim Sagibgareev: что ли блат микро на минималках хотя бы из этого уже это уже можно сильно обереться тем что это будет интересно целевой аудитории потому что это будет нашим языком описано нашими словами
Maxim Sagibgareev: и это будет реально то что он волнует клиентов потому что это он не встречаем каждый день это у наших клиентов
Maxim Sagibgareev: понимаете да и это вот супер важно мне кажется вот именно вот это сейчас нас отделяет вот от ну типа ультимативного вот промеж глаз попадания аудитории которая нас там не знает типа
Maxim Sagibgareev: вот это вот экспертности вот это вот наша какое -то видение то есть если мы вот этим начнем делиться и говорить там вот ну типа
Александр Бондаренко: мы поняли
Maxim Sagibgareev: что мы можем цеплять на тему вузов. Вот мы не провели, ну, запустили рекламу и поняли, что тема вузов очень цепляет, профессия цепляет сложно, там, поступление, ну, тоже там как -то
Maxim Sagibgareev: не очень понятно, а тема вузов вообще
Александр Бондаренко: прям, ну, качает,
Maxim Sagibgareev: то есть люди откликаются. Хорошо, что мы можем там на эту там тему собрать? Ну, то есть, вот,
Александр Бондаренко: как бы мы можем точнее, так, мы можем этой аудитории, которая интересуется вузами там той или иной степени то есть там родители для детей все остальное им какой -то контент показывать
Александр Бондаренко: какой контент показывать вот такой который я сейчас до этого перечислил то есть мы как бы удочку бросаем мы научились бросать удочку
Maxim Sagibgareev: хорошо но
Александр Бондаренко: чем вкуснее червячка мы туда подкинем
Maxim Sagibgareev: и чем круче тем
Александр Бондаренко: издатель будет рыбок и говорится круче будет рыба пока что у нас тоненький крючочек и червячка там почти нету
Александр Бондаренко: вот сейчас секунду секунду
Maxim Sagibgareev: секунду червячок для
Александр Бондаренко: тебя это что червячок для меня это вот как раз единицы контента
Maxim Sagibgareev: вот там мощный крутой
Александр Бондаренко: чек -лист мощный
Maxim Sagibgareev: крутой там
Александр Бондаренко: видео например мощная статья например прикольная которая крутая которая там рассказывает про какую -то боль и и показывает и нашим экспертности нашими тадологи то что мы вообще крутые
Александр Бондаренко: например то есть чем то чем можно вот кинуть клиента такой о да блин ну конечно крутые вопросов нету он смотрел ознакомился и понял что круто то есть мы называем доверие мы вызываем
Александр Бондаренко: доверие то есть я знаете в очередной раз сейчас вот даже наверное больше чем до этого я понял насколько важен вот купюрайтинг и как вот ну вот просто формулируются и пишутся слова то
Александр Бондаренко: есть поэтому люди очень сильно делают вывод по они доверяют
Maxim Sagibgareev: вот тому что напишем это просто они
Александр Бондаренко: видят что это какая дешевая
Maxim Sagibgareev: херня на кинерина нейронка и все уже
Александр Бондаренко: с этого складывается дает
Maxim Sagibgareev: инфо сотка прям
Александр Бондаренко: вообще то есть я прям вижу насколько это важно для нашего методика пипец прям вообще небо и земля
Александр Бондаренко: до услышал тебя все четко говоришь я согласен то что мы тоже сами замешаны тут как пишем что говорим насчет материал все понял вернись быстро к игре которую ты слайд был давай до конца
Александр Бондаренко: еще быстро пробегусь давай давай кричиталь гектар вот и прощение экономика давай вниз здесь экономика вниз следом вот у каждого показателя свои вопросы смотрите какие показатели прикольные
Александр Бондаренко: видимость интерес выраженный интерес покупка игровое поведение активная аудитория держание качество опыта эффект рекламы экономикой производства
Александр Бондаренко: очень важный слайдик потому что здесь по сути вся цепочка конверсии лишь каналы подачи решения там общение аудитория проверка спроса ценное условия управление темп на нагрузка и регулярность
Александр Бондаренко: причины возврата исправления причин бюджет канала по
Maxim Sagibgareev: сути общение аудитория то что ты сейчас говоришь
Александр Бондаренко: это про интерес и мы хотим сделать его выраженным да да да да да вот наверное вот это как раз и общение с аудиторией и язык общения аудитории как раз таки ведет к следующему шагу то
Александр Бондаренко: есть к выраженному
Maxim Sagibgareev: интересу а интересно добавить
Александр Бондаренко: список желаемого там
Maxim Sagibgareev: ими например
Александр Бондаренко: запросить доступ запросить доступ до потом уже покупка да вот кстати давай тоже вот хорошо раз мы проиграть есть такой часто момент когда игра еще ну типа готовится большая игра вот
Александр Бондаренко: например не знаю знаете ли нет какой -нибудь war thunder например конечно игра там про самолеты сейчас уже там и танки корабли но когда -то это была игра про самолеты это из да да только
Александр Бондаренко: самолет личная история вот я знаю такую компанию всю жизнь делали они одиночные игры но потом стремлю
Maxim Sagibgareev: там вон то фанцы они решили сделать такой свой world of tags но про самолеты и типа это
Александр Бондаренко: был о я где -то увидел видео на ютюбе что анонсированная
Maxim Sagibgareev: игра которая называется war thunder которая будет онлайн
Александр Бондаренко: многопользовательская она еще не готова выйдет хрен знает когда я такой о прикольно пошел гуглить загуглим их сайт увидел что у них там прикольные видосики как летают самолеты и типа
Александр Бондаренко: подпишитесь на закрытую альфа версию я такой о прикольно подпишусь подписываюсь и как мне говорят чувак смотри доступ очень ограниченный мы пускаем туда
Maxim Sagibgareev: только тех людей которые готовы закрыты закрытая альфа тест это называется да действительно там очень ограничено то есть только либо ты чуть ли не должен не заслужить то есть ты должен
Maxim Sagibgareev: там баги оформлять то есть это не для игры и то есть мы пускаем туда очень редко я такой ok я готов типа ждать я не готов сильно участвовать но я по чесноку себе ответил но
Александр Бондаренко: у этой игры есть комьюнити и сообщества на тот момент у них был форум и у них была по моему группа вконтакте где они выкладывали какие -то посты комментировали и там около игры я подписался
Александр Бондаренко: сразу на все есть там один официальный какой -то канал и форум где выкладывать и один допустим там фанатский который уже там смогу это скриншоты с макует видео обсуждает и как бы вот
Александр Бондаренко: пожалуйста общение аудитория уже есть инфраструктура то есть там люди комментируют там о прикольно
Maxim Sagibgareev: блин интересно
Александр Бондаренко: самолеты типа я еще вообще в игру не играл у меня уже подогрели блин я еще ни копейки не заплатил но я как бы готов вариться и ждать и типа то есть уже ну наверное это выраженный уже
Александр Бондаренко: интерес случае уже уже
Maxim Sagibgareev: до вырезать если был бы просто там ну под форма ну вам спасибо всего доброго и все типа это бы ну блин когда уж выйдет тогда уж поиграю а так получилось так что там через полгода мне
Maxim Sagibgareev: реально пришло приглашение на почту я зашел в альфа версию поиграл охерела того как не понравилось действительно
Александр Бондаренко: сделок уже на тот момент классно потому что ниже готова была база не тонучки не а весь симуляторы делали здесь не было или управление мышкой самолету
Maxim Sagibgareev: и как бы реальная физика самолета подчиняется просто курсору просто ультра реалистичный самолет
Александр Бондаренко: курсором условно кирилл насколько это офигенно сделано это супер как бы ну даже аркадном какой -то степени но при этом реалистично и типа я такой все ну песец ну типа я погнали и то
Александр Бондаренко: есть я пошел играть и в какой -то момент я там через время то даже премиум аккаунт покупал дать какой там премиум самолет купил за каких -то 300 400 рублей на типа по приколу тратить
Александр Бондаренко: транзакции проводить уже все ты уже по пути уже клиент да да да да хотя игра еще даже тогда было разработки там у нас тоже на фото альфа версия сейчас нашего проекта
Maxim Sagibgareev: они уже собрали комьюнити ранее собрали фанатов своих которые готовы терпеть там баги что -то не работает что -то еще и очень надо им очень интересно и им постоянно подливает какой
Игорь А.: -то интерес как -то с ними общаются ну то есть они там им разрешают какие -то свои идеи предлагай они сразу горечу нравится что не нравится ну типа
Игорь А.: много там всего было ну да от солны кто круто то есть ты говоришь чтобы мы как бы на каком этапе ты сейчас хочешь чтобы мы были готовы на каком готовности все по игре брать как ты видишь
Игорь А.: следующий наш шаг то есть мы же уже на каком -то этапе есть что тебе важно докрутить чтобы мы доделали уже и ты был такой довольны мы не идем к финальному ну просто как бы какой вот
Игорь А.: наверное вот это вот здесь же написано да вот решение общения общения и аудитория вот мне кажется вот с видимостью мы вопрос ну типа хорошо мы можем создавать
Maxim Sagibgareev: показы закинули сколько -то денег появились показы хорошо теперь наши так вот здесь вот нам нужно чтобы мы начали общаться с аудиторией на ее языке а общаться вот еще раз и язык нашей
Maxim Sagibgareev: аудитории это доверие это экспертность и это ну я не знаю мне кажется
Александр Бондаренко: для наших историй
Maxim Sagibgareev: прям ну дига важно какие -то материалы пощупать еще до оплаты кейсы и кейсы да да да вот круто вообще супер дополнить кейсы не важно вообще то есть это все общение целевой
Александр Бондаренко: аудитории и
Maxim Sagibgareev: то есть и нам нужно вот сделать вот это вообще обещание это обещание это говорится о том что
Александр Бондаренко: как как бы о чем мы
Игорь А.: говорим ребят будет видео будет авиасимулятор крутой там или там еще что то есть как бы это наше обещание на тоже нам нужно перевести систему профориентации там еще что то ну то есть
Игорь А.: когда я понял нам нужно передать выраженный
Maxim Sagibgareev: интерес для того чтобы
Игорь А.: перевести вынужденный интерес
Maxim Sagibgareev: нам нужно сделать затравочку вот посыпать крутыми как бы экспертными материалами видео контентом упаковка вопрос этап покупки у нас уже сделан заказов заказов и заказов и покупки до
Maxim Sagibgareev: любому кидаем ссылку оплачивает покупают и пошли дальше уже то есть как бы он у нас вот именно можно рисовать вот можно рисовать прикольно кстати
Игорь А.: вот у нас пока что я вижу пробел вот здесь вот то есть спад такой прям на на этапе когда людям ну интересно мы нашли тему которую интересуют вуза поступления ништяк люди готовы вестись
Игорь А.: кликать оставлять контакты хорошо теперь нам нужно выраженный интерес когда они ну как мы с ними как -то общаемся супер спасибо цене это по просто не то что обрываю хочу игоря подключить
Игорь А.: быстренько игорь заказать и нас к жизни тоже
Maxim Sagibgareev: слушай
Maxim Sagibgareev: но я вижу саша классный большой опыт в играх которого
Игорь А.: у меня к сожалению нет и но это все круто и как раз таки знаешь просто вот по партнерке там я тоже людям говорю, вы сейчас первые пользователи, мы не хотим пускать прям всех экспертов,
Игорь А.: которые у нас есть, а у нас их там больше 50, мы вот просто выбрали у вас небольшую когорту, зайдите, попробуйте вот этот наш демо продукт, поэтому все применимо, просто разный
Maxim Sagibgareev: немножко масштаб, скорее всего, там, то, о чем говорит Саша, там были, условно говоря, сотни или тысячи человек, у нас там будут десятки эти человек которые будут первыми евангелистами
Maxim Sagibgareev: этого всего движения а смотри а
Игорь А.: есть разные студии есть хобби
Maxim Sagibgareev: студии там автор просто сам хобби из такой потом инди студии а потом да было и 3 было и надо
Игорь А.: да я поначал мы можем быть на уровне просто хобби стов пока
Игорь А.: которые не коммерческие хотят
Говорящий 7: ну просто хобби хобби игры
Maxim Sagibgareev: запускают хобби уровень
Maxim Sagibgareev: нет и это уже команды но там может быть там команда большая а
Игорь А.: это
Maxim Sagibgareev: уже желание коммерчески как бы из успешно сделать продукт хоббисты мы протестировали весь им 180 тысяч карточек хоббейсты за весь срок игры максимально что там что -то 10 тысяч долларов
Maxim Sagibgareev: за по всем играм то есть нету больше 10 тысяч долларов прибыли ничего до дохода нету на хоббейстов вообще были прибыли дохода да да то есть выручки нету а выручка там на дабл а там
Maxim Sagibgareev: близ приближается к за все время там понял то есть это чисто вот вводные чуваки которые либо залетные либо просто там какой -то проект закинули посмотрели и так далее то есть нам нужно
Maxim Sagibgareev: выйти в индю категорию перейти я понял в индюк категорию чтобы упаковка была хорошая и классно мы сидели окей давай дальше идем вернее нет и хотел мысль сказать закончить игорь закончу
Maxim Sagibgareev: а но я о том говорил что у нас плюс -минус даже интуитивно без вот этого то что сказал саша так идет вот и сообщество уже напрашивается какое -то да и закрытое тестирование то есть
Maxim Sagibgareev: ну это тоже мупротинг то есть это тоже мальчик типа проблематика до проблематика экспертов получается проблематика родителей и детей подростков между ними и в целом понял и проблематика
Maxim Sagibgareev: еще экспертов почему сообщества зачем сообщества она там принципе на слуху вся есть ну там типа я я не разбираюсь много всего куда дальше двигаться такие же похожие задачки но это отдельная
Maxim Sagibgareev: тема да получается и как я помню ты когда привлекал ты делал фокус на на том что вы будете больше зарабатывать правильно ну человек цеплял именно это или что -то другое? Ты знаешь,
Maxim Sagibgareev: условно говоря, две категории,
Игорь А.: которые я увидел. Тем, которым неловко про деньги говорить, и они такие больше в чё там в продукте. И те, которым про деньги окей говорить, ну короче всех их интересовал
Maxim Sagibgareev: продукт, то есть что продавать. Даже так, Те, кто
Игорь А.: не про деньги, их условно говоря, что внутри методологии, а тех, кто про деньги, такие, как я могу это продать, дайте мне смыслы.
Игорь А.: Дайте мне смыслы,
Игорь А.: можешь объяснить, что ты делаешь? То есть дайте мне понятные закрывающие месседжи, которые мне помогут продажу эту сделать. То есть почему они должны купить, мои условно говоря семьи.
Игорь А.: И тогда я шел в методологию и давал эти смыслы опять же, то есть через ту же методологию, почему я вас тогда созвал, чтобы мне больше контекста. По сути, мы готовы продавать разные
Игорь А.: прикольные
Maxim Sagibgareev: решения, продукты и так далее, как эксперты, пусть они будут не в нашей экспертизе.
Игорь А.: Только объясните, зачем, почему,
Maxim Sagibgareev: кому, как
Игорь А.: и что еще там
Maxim Sagibgareev: было?
Игорь А.: Да, чтобы было понимание хотя бы поверхностное. Во -первых, сметчить, то есть семье нужно, не нужно. А во -вторых, как продать.
Maxim Sagibgareev: что говорить что там внутри есть чтобы вот как порекомендовать и сделать продажу да да да так хорошо супер понял
Игорь А.: давайте дальше до конца там еще сколько осталось страничка ли все уже две страницы вот стойте на это то
Maxim Sagibgareev: есть смотрите тут как бы вообще вся задумка
Игорь А.: ну такая аналитическая наши в принципе вы же тоже занимаетесь анализом вы смотрите там конверсии все и
Maxim Sagibgareev: потом делаете микро выводы то есть у нас по сути сейчас запуск пилотников многочисленный и мы выбираем окей а какая выстрелит игра ну образно какая структура то есть на разных этапах
Maxim Sagibgareev: эволюции создания самой игры там демо прототип еще что -то вот вы
Игорь А.: закинули сейчас прототип вебинара хоп он может выстроить что -то живое как бы супер также тут получается
Maxim Sagibgareev: нужен стильный анализ потому что ну как бы чтобы конкурировать и же должен забрать этих ребят а чтобы забрать ты должен понять о чем на самом то деле нужно вот ну тут про игры больше
Maxim Sagibgareev: и как бы какие там были таблицы карточки как то есть игры есть версии у игры есть игрок есть события какое -то ну то есть когорта видите когорты важны очень тогда можно совместимый
Maxim Sagibgareev: анализ сделать когорт запусков когда например там нам зашло по рекламной кампании там в этот месяц там 200 человек вот это однако горта потом еще какая -то рекламная компания другая
Maxim Sagibgareev: уже когорта вот тоже поизучайте как это с этим работать вот точно он так делать вот ну конкретный сеанс это вот прошло мероприятие например с учителем со мной там еще с кем -то с экспертом
Maxim Sagibgareev: и он оставил отзыв и дальнейшего действия вот чем там дальше делать ну либо внутри чего они делали внутри сессии там какие упражнения делали какой материал прошли и так далее у нас
Maxim Sagibgareev: запись это тоже игорь тестировал уже или нет что именно или у нас а у нас было закрыто тестирование короче у нас есть уже практически рабочая схема там с пакетами что за делают и вот
Maxim Sagibgareev: как мы сейчас созваниваемся мы можем все делать нашей системе
Maxim Sagibgareev: да и об этом говорил я кстати тоже это людям
Александр Бондаренко: уже как бы говорю что
Maxim Sagibgareev: у нас это в разработке там финальной версии ну да а что ты говоришь какие -то фичи или или плюсы какие -то говоришь но люди говорят отчетом дальше будет а я как эксперт что там смогу
Maxim Sagibgareev: не смогу они же и о себе таки таком мои электронные продукты цифровые можно там нельзя будет мои услуги размещать да можно будет а там что еще ну вот говорю звонки мы внутренние делаем
Maxim Sagibgareev: то есть про
Александр Бондаренко: профиль рассказываю что есть внутренний профиль
Maxim Sagibgareev: который формируется на основании этой профориентации и на основании созвонов с экспертами то есть мы делаем внутреннюю программу похожую на зум с помощью которой вы можете созвониться
Maxim Sagibgareev: и весь контекст который будет на
Александр Бондаренко: встрече он транскрибируется и разложится в как раз таки профиль ученика таким образом
Maxim Sagibgareev: даже если вы там что -то забудете или нужно будет освежить там или посмотреть прогресс это все будет в профиле круто круто круто то есть ты по сути тоже говоришь смотрите у вас тоже
Maxim Sagibgareev: есть более там какие -то операционные задачи ваши как экспертов мы их тоже закроем да я присутствовал на какой -то встречи мы обсуждали это все поэтому я им все это транслирую что будем
Maxim Sagibgareev: делать как бы не вернется да тоже такое что было связку что вот вы находите на профиру но вы можете провести у нас это супер как бы то в этом есть задача и мы продадим ваши услуги дороже
Maxim Sagibgareev: то есть то же самое у нас другая там аудитория более качественно но здесь смотри то есть это не ну как бы я чуть другим зазором как бы что даже аудитория которая у них покупает они
Maxim Sagibgareev: же все равно
Александр Бондаренко: продолжают лет
Maxim Sagibgareev: генитин сами лет гените на профи ру но потом они все равно куда -то идут зум или в телемост так идите к нам и у нас проводить ну да и кстати профиль из вашего студента тоже будет у
Maxim Sagibgareev: нас он и получит профориентацию потом вы можете более точно ему какие -то свои дополнительные услуги продавать еще вот кстати это так открыто говорить нужно и и я прям думаю что нужно
Maxim Sagibgareev: еще просто ссылка на регистрацию вот в кабинет сто процентов просто так хорошо смотрите возвращаемся к статистике к анализу то есть сашка себе то что смотри тут очень прикольно они
Maxim Sagibgareev: говорят про пересечения если ты посмотришь ты свежая постоянная группа какая -то именно постоянно должна быть потом одинаковый возраст этого для игры что важно есть данные когда отсутствуют
Maxim Sagibgareev: пропуски и когда нули это отдельная история то есть пропуске подозревает 0
Александр Бондаренко: если данных
Maxim Sagibgareev: нет это тоже мы там ну сто восемь тысяч карточек посмотрели поэтому как бы тут
Maxim Sagibgareev: важный показатель когда ты собираешь данные что пропуск не значит что 0 вот потом что важно по данным важен разброс смотрите среднее число может очень сильно быть завышенным чем мы
Maxim Sagibgareev: увидели то есть там среднее количество продаж на индии например там не знаю 10000 в месяц 0 давайте в года неважно например медианная ну то есть самое частое то есть типичное что типично
Maxim Sagibgareev: этому рынку она например там 1000 то есть в 10 раз меньше вот а
Александр Бондаренко: если без разброса смотри есть процентиль и ну то есть давай по росту возьмем у тебя какой рост у
Александр Бондаренко: меня до метро 80 метров 80 вот если мы не знаем процентилий то мы не можем сказать насколько ты высокий то есть мы можем сказать что ты выше кого то там да если так а насколько только
Александр Бондаренко: не можем так вот бы понимаю разброс представьте всю планету мы взяли и по росту их расположили теперь мы видим каком ты проценте ли находишься и также по играм можно посмотреть какие
Александр Бондаренко: игры сколько денег в ком проценте ли заработали
Александр Бондаренко: и и и что ты понимал например вот если мы возьмем 30 топовых карточек это 99
Maxim Sagibgareev: процентов
Александр Бондаренко: дохода то есть на последующие 70 процентов карточек у тебя там доли процентов ну я так же как все ушки топ -3 там забирают и все бабки вообще это во всем это во всем поэтому поэтому
Александр Бондаренко: смотри как бы тут вот эти вот ну как бы разброс то нужны то есть там первый ну вообще разброс делится примерно так то есть первый процентиль и 99 процентиль потом улеза нам 5 10 25
Александр Бондаренко: то есть 25 значит что есть 75 понял если есть
Maxim Sagibgareev: 10 значит есть 90 если там есть 5 на 95
Александр Бондаренко: есть и ты видишь
Maxim Sagibgareev: в рамках всех данных внутри если у тебя 25 75 ты видишь середину и
Александр Бондаренко: И ты видишь середину, например, цены за игру, то есть нижняя часть у тебя цены за игру 25 баксов, средняя, верхняя часть у тебя 55
Maxim Sagibgareev: баксов. А, например,
Александр Бондаренко: самая дорогая игра может быть 250 долларов. И там будет их всего три карточки, понимаешь, да?
Александр Бондаренко: И по доходу так же, и по доходу в месяц так же, и по доходу в год так же, ну и так далее. то есть вот это вот вся метрика разброса то что мы увидели потом проверка чувствительности
Александр Бондаренко: но тут про модель как бы как ты моделируешь это все это это больше к структуре то есть
Александр Бондаренко: если ты берешь последние два года и выстраиваешь график на будущее например то у тебя может график один быть а если возьмешь пять лет то может быть другой график это чувствительность
Александр Бондаренко: адекватно короче рассматривать ну как вот фондовый рынок например думаешь газпром будет расти но уже рост последние там два часа а как бы что будет если мы возьмем больше чем два часа
Александр Бондаренко: если два месяца посмотрим какой будет вариант ну и так далее вот и потом развлечение видишь у тебя есть факт
Maxim Sagibgareev: есть оценка и сценарий
Александр Бондаренко: то есть есть факт конкретный но факты с фактами оценки с оценками и оценки про факты то есть ты не можешь факты с оценками соотнести или сценарии со фактами соотнести
Александр Бондаренко: вот тоже
Maxim Sagibgareev: важная история как бы и и по пересечению если посмотришь
Александр Бондаренко: аудитории опыт получается что у тебя есть там сегмент прототип там инструкция версия каналы предложения то есть какое предложение на каком канале на ютюбе вы говорите
Maxim Sagibgareev: на такое то там здесь
Александр Бондаренко: мы делаем через рекламу в к нужно вот такую то связку и потом на вебинар цена креатив регион видеть источник трафика то есть откуда приходит подходящие интересы покупка потом какие
Александр Бондаренко: разные как разные люди понимают одну механику
Александр Бондаренко: где рушится обещанный опыт и кто возвращается вот как раз то что мы сейчас и делаем получается не у вас даже обещанного опыта нету мы должны ты говоришь ребята нужны информация про
Александр Бондаренко: какой опыт человек получит он нам придет чем получит дайте всю инфу что ему ожидать весь мир звездных войн ему расскажите
Александр Бондаренко: так окей аналоги ресурсы но это уже по конкурентам из смотреть то есть если сравнивать аналоги очень важно видишь например одна игра запустилась одного уровня представь игра запустилась
Александр Бондаренко: в мае а другая например там в апреле в апреле ну и нам нужно возраст их посмотреть возрастом и смотрим сегодня а теперь нужно нормализировать чтобы одинаковый был возраст тогда будет
Александр Бондаренко: одинаковое сравнение и допустим по жанру еще сделали по механикам еще одинаково
Maxim Sagibgareev: и теперь мы можем понять стоит ли нам входить в
Александр Бондаренко: этот рынок с этой игрой
Александр Бондаренко: сможем конкурировать механику посмотрели ну типа скопировать лучших вот как на ютюбе говорят же смотришь на рабочие стратегии типа просто ну по свою нишу смотришь топовые видео которые
Александр Бондаренко: залетели по аналогии на руку шла то же самое с играми ты смотришь какие уже в стиме
Maxim Sagibgareev: там продаются
Александр Бондаренко: ну и потом думаешь строить оттуда заходить или нет вот и тут вопрос бюджета да ну продажи дальше порог окупаемости максимальная нехватка денег ну то есть сколько нужно прожить там какие
Александр Бондаренко: траты вот иди дальше последним девятому
Александр Бондаренко: так туда
Александр Бондаренко: видеть смотри успех игрока успех проекта устойчивая студии разные задачи
Александр Бондаренко: ну да и тут
Александр Бондаренко: вот разные виды то есть законченная авторская игра ну ты как бы сюжет прошел до конца дошел и по сути тут не
Maxim Sagibgareev: важно что man free active users
Александр Бондаренко: ну то есть там количество активных пользователей низкая ну как -то ненормально мне все равно миллионы играют например доходит до конца и удовлетворенные вот потом вторая совместная
Александр Бондаренко: платная игра тут уже важно сколько потому что тебе же нужно как бы совместно играет тут вопрос а сколько сейчас сети онлайн смогу ли я найти себе партнера образ вот ну и бесплатно это
Александр Бондаренко: же там к это сервисная игра другой тип получается
Maxim Sagibgareev: вот тебе обещанный опыт тоже есть
Александр Бондаренко: ты говоришь ребят нам нужно целостная история чтобы человек пришел понял какая история его ждет дальше захотел зайти потом а по факту с экспертами что нам нужно у нас совместная игра
Александр Бондаренко: то
Александр Бондаренко: есть чтобы эксперты работали с не экспертами это по сути совместная игра где у тебя должны минимум два там встретиться в онлайне и потом возвращение с друзьями а и
Игорь А.: колен совместная игра
Maxim Sagibgareev: ну вот как бы с
Александр Бондаренко: одной стороны хочется сделать какую
Maxim Sagibgareev: -то несовместную
Игорь А.: начать хотя бы с
Александр Бондаренко: несовместный чтобы мы не зависели от экспертов чтобы уже вот этот продукт у нас сейчас был
Игорь А.: и он был целостный пусть он будет
Александр Бондаренко: даже бесплатный сервисный вот как бы бесплатный сервисный продукт не играя продукт так давайте развивающийся
Maxim Sagibgareev: опыт регулярные причины вернуться ну да наверное
Александр Бондаренко: правильно
Александр Бондаренко: и кстати смотрите у меня я вот
Maxim Sagibgareev: общался с игорем
Александр Бондаренко: с тобой не говорил тебе тоже спрашивают то есть
Александр Бондаренко: про про ориентации регулярная причина вернуться ну раз в год это только вот когда тебе там 15 16 нас лет а другой регулярной причины нету ты говоришь на профессии плохо конвертируется
Александр Бондаренко: то есть людям получается неинтересно информационный продукт профессии посмотреть нет нет не то что плохо конвертируется то что широко то есть туда приходят типа люди за там и старые
Александр Бондаренко: с детьми из детей то есть профессия широко же ухо а если у нас будет вот не будет задачи им что -то продать а просто вот ознакомьтесь с чем -нибудь что вам интересно про профессии ну
Александр Бондаренко: и решим сами что это же наш регулярные причины вернуться мы я просто про это
Maxim Sagibgareev: думаю регулярную причину вернуться
Александр Бондаренко: и
Александр Бондаренко: вот у тебя развивающийся опыт смотреть и бесплатник бесплатник бесплатник возвращаешься что -то бесплатно получаешь вот авиасейлс поискал что -то посмотрел а потом взял залогинился
Александр Бондаренко: и купил и за этом шахматы бесплатно играл не за полгода и мезы заколебали этой подпиской и там реально потом начало прикольно что -то быть типа там анализ какой -то дают аналит аналитику
Александр Бондаренко: я подпишу и до сих пор с не слазу для этого нужен какой -то полезный инструмент типа либо какая -то полезная за которые возвращаются и которую люди впитывают смотрят читают и все остальное
Александр Бондаренко: на нормальном языке подчеркиваю не нейронно либо либо какой -то инструмент по типу там не знаю загугли получили там рейтинг вузов или оцени реально то свои шансы вот эти потому что
Александр Бондаренко: у нас прошел вот я а а можешь еще дать
Maxim Sagibgareev: две идеи быстро вот какой -то инструмент
Александр Бондаренко: и говоришь что -то инструментально это какие -то еще мысли которые у тебя сейчас из маркетинга уже складываются что -то инструментальное ну какой -то ассистент нейронный который может
Александр Бондаренко: что -то спросить не знаю может быть по выбору гуза может по
Maxim Sagibgareev: домашним заданием
Александр Бондаренко: а
Александр Бондаренко: вот это простое может быть и
Александр Бондаренко: ну тут наверное тоже про контент полезные но типа там вот и не знаю в серии вот как на гид курсе постоянно уроки пополняется может на youtube канал просто как уроки ну исходя из всех
Александр Бондаренко: от наших аудитории которыми ты сейчас докручиваешь пишешь что будет полезно для них какой контент полезный прям ты видишь какой ну что -то с выбором вуза там либо там оцени свои шансы
Александр Бондаренко: либо вот там все грузы мы вроде бы как бы сделали там вуз навигатор но он же не сказать что он как -то супер практично выглядит он скорее вот такой сёшный он пилотник да он прям нормальный
Александр Бондаренко: хороший мвп -пилотник ну да даже даже еще не альфа версия или альфа или альфа
Александр Бондаренко: хорошо духом он
Вадим Х.: альфа даже
Maxim Sagibgareev: не версия самец вот
Игорь А.: но
Maxim Sagibgareev: по сути он
Александр Бондаренко: пилотник хорошо
Maxim Sagibgareev: ребят
Александр Бондаренко: если этот пилотник станет не пилотником вы будете довольны правильно да
Maxim Sagibgareev: ну возможно это гипотеза
Maxim Sagibgareev: если
Александр Бондаренко: получится я буду доволен
Maxim Sagibgareev: хорошо я я я саша прошу пофантазировать так как будто это случилось
Александр Бондаренко: и похеру приставь что ты бог вот ты как хочешь так и делаешь вот убираем гипотезу просто мне нужно именно конкретику из твоего из твоей экспертизы выжилку
Maxim Sagibgareev: прямо сейчас дай пожалуйста
Александр Бондаренко: это прошу прям но смотри из моей экспертизы ну я думаю
Maxim Sagibgareev: смотри вот люди логически приходят
Александр Бондаренко: как не допустить ошибки при выборах вуза как поступить в топовые там вуз любой мира так как они лагину логически приходит на этом запрос на ну представим что у нас есть такой продукт
Александр Бондаренко: даже бесплатный конечно он усилит нам общую воротку где мы скажем а у нас есть вот такой вот сервис инструмент услуга кабинет где вы можете найти и вот воспользоваться вот это конечно
Александр Бондаренко: это только усилить и инфа сотка
Maxim Sagibgareev: будет
Александр Бондаренко: а если они будут смотреть просто пользователи приходите уходить вот чтобы тоже было принципе сами на порядке ничего
Maxim Sagibgareev: не покупать если будет я хочу то есть
Александр Бондаренко: регулярная причина вернуться
Maxim Sagibgareev: и вот
Александр Бондаренко: написано развивающийся опыт а допустим он ну допустим он развивается но вот первые его этапы развития они простенькие как бы ну души атаку так макс такой вопрос вот смотри по скринингу
Александр Бондаренко: вот у нас много ну там больше там 50 до человек оставили прошли скрининг и все то есть вот про такой ты говоришь или нет я приму
Maxim Sagibgareev: именно что есть
Александр Бондаренко: что то то
Maxim Sagibgareev: есть это микроигра скрининг а я про какие то еще микроигр внутри
Александр Бондаренко: бесплатный я для разные разделы если прошел ну как ты говоришь вот посмотреть вузы да то есть окей посмотрела скрининги
Maxim Sagibgareev: круто с
Игорь А.: нейроассистентом поговорил
Александр Бондаренко: поговорил супер просто шутку
Maxim Sagibgareev: а данешь то
Александр Бондаренко: что типа пришли посмотрели типа то что мы не продаем а просто вот сделан еще не купили
Maxim Sagibgareev: на получили
Игорь А.: ценность да то есть она расслаблась
Maxim Sagibgareev: и
Игорь А.: платформу по сути скачали на на iphone седят
Maxim Sagibgareev: игру и в нее периодически
Александр Бондаренко: заходит что там делают какие -то циклы проходят циклы какие -то проходят вот и как бы постепенно больше какие -то более сложные и там им какое -то сообщение слушая возни про каунта
Александр Бондаренко: у нас еще есть профиль 360 или там профиль 10 хочу то еще что то но это потом я хочу как бы на этапе бесплатного сделать то что ну как бы я я слышу тебя нейроконсультант уже отдельная
Александр Бондаренко: тема я понял то что вузы вся эта история поступления отдельно короче даже вчера закидывал в нейронку нейронка ну я не супер я другую задачу делал но она между делом не закинула я проанализировала
Александр Бондаренко: запросы в интернете и зарубежные российские и все говорят оцените свои
Maxim Sagibgareev: шансы то есть значит
Александр Бондаренко: это работает история оценить свои шансы в копилку
Maxim Sagibgareev: того что очень круто людям
Александр Бондаренко: важно что -то оценить оценить какие -то
Maxim Sagibgareev: шансы оценить свою
Александр Бондаренко: насколько это подходит до согласованность этого вуза ну да мои баллы там какие мои баллы может быть вуз теоретически
Maxim Sagibgareev: оценить то что
Александр Бондаренко: направление подходит ребят вы тоже не молчите чего там спрятались канарейках своих давайте власти очень хорошо идет мысль зачем перебивать добавлять ее чё тут мы же не философы тут
Александр Бондаренко: думать давайте тоже
Александр Бондаренко: вернись вернись обратно вернись где было не уходи туда пока не уходи что здесь
Александр Бондаренко: Ну,
Maxim Sagibgareev: смотрите,
Александр Бондаренко: главный цикл, вот давайте посмотрим. Вот, в законченной игре освоить, ну, наверное, освоить, узнать там, да? Освоить, тут просто маркетинга нет, я уже вижу по этому документу, не хватает
Александр Бондаренко: пару этапов в начале. Освоить, пройти, осмыслить, порекомендовать.
Александр Бондаренко: Вот, освоить, видите, такой долгий может быть процесс освоения, потом ты проходишь, а потом ты рекомендуешь, да, допустим. Это вот авторская игра, какой -то прикольный сюжет, там прям
Александр Бондаренко: задумка идет.
Maxim Sagibgareev: Вот, потом,
Александр Бондаренко: ну, главный цикл. Вот на Profi .ru есть тоже главный цикл. На Яндекс .Доставке есть тоже главный цикл. Идем в платная игра. Собраться, сыграть, улучшить, повторить. Собраться как раз
Maxim Sagibgareev: -таки сообщество.
Александр Бондаренко: Сыграть это вместе, какое -то взаимодействие должно быть совместно.
Maxim Sagibgareev: Я улучшился, ну как бы меня
Александр Бондаренко: прокачали, мои скиллы или еще что -то.
Александр Бондаренко: Правильно ведь? Улучшение должно случиться. Я поставил звездочки. Отзыв должен еще быть здесь. И повторить.
Александр Бондаренко: И
Maxim Sagibgareev: до собраться еще что
Александр Бондаренко: -то должно быть. Правильно? принципе окей теперь смотрим бесплатно да ну вот как раз таки начать
Maxim Sagibgareev: прогрессировать
Игорь А.: вернуться участвовать начать прогрессировать вернуться участвовать сейчас все поймете я сейчас вас в виду издалека
Александр Бондаренко: просто я сам тут концепт
Maxim Sagibgareev: формирую себя проверка качества если
Александр Бондаренко: это авторская игра то есть насколько все понятно целевые сцены классные то есть завершенность есть до удовлетворение есть. Окей, если это у нас совместная игра. Вклад после переменных...
Александр Бондаренко: Нет. Качество матчей... О, ну, качество, короче, консультации и качество уроков. То есть, получается, помнишь, Игорь, ты говорил, мы оцениваем процесс и мы оцениваем результат, да?
Александр Бондаренко: НПС, и что там еще было? НПС.
Maxim Sagibgareev: CSI.
Александр Бондаренко: CSI.
Александр Бондаренко: Какой -то еще был показатель, нет?
Александр Бондаренко: Да, был. Могу сейчас посмотреть в своих старых материалах.
Александр Бондаренко: надо посмотреть все показатели то есть про процессы про результаты в связку это вот у нас связь до связь это общение между то что они общаются легко и как раз таки мы еще доработали
Александр Бондаренко: вроде как я совместно уже уже хороший результат приглашение то что могут можно всех приглашать я и я эксперт приглашаю приходи ко мне вот на ссылка тебе тебе тебе тебе приходи ко мне
Александр Бондаренко: или там я эксперт вот смотри у другого эксперта есть классный сервис на дело дело дело и квотки и сам студент такой слушай я хочу я хочу вот это решить я хочу то есть шахматах ты можешь
Александр Бондаренко: по -разному ты можешь автоматически чтоб тебя замачивала в игру я могу сам сделать образно в рынок сказать ребят готов поиграть 5 минутку вот кто хочет давайте нажимайте и сыграем
Александр Бондаренко: то есть можно идти от предложения к запросу, а можно от запроса к предложению идти.
Александр Бондаренко: Ну и совместимость тоже важная история.
Maxim Sagibgareev: То
Александр Бондаренко: есть да, я учитель английского, о, я хочу английский. Встречаются, если без деталей, то один учитель английского на русском,
Александр Бондаренко: он с русского на английском, да, учит, допустим, и не умеет как бы учить на английском. Может быть, он умеет. Надо тоже понять. И он учит, например, ЕГЭ. А другой тоже, допустим, русский
Александр Бондаренко: английский, то есть русский нативный учит английский навык.
Maxim Sagibgareev: но хочет не ЕГЭ,
Александр Бондаренко: а
Александр Бондаренко: GCSE какой
Maxim Sagibgareev: -нибудь, или там испанский
Александр Бондаренко: какой -нибудь, квалификацию другую, не знаю,
Игорь А.: американскую, TOEFL какой -то сделать. Все, уже несовместимость.
Игорь А.: То есть тут должна быть совместимость для совместного. Вот, и тут какая бесплатная, да, идет история. То есть мы
Maxim Sagibgareev: смотрим проверку
Игорь А.: качества. Вот, удержание когор. То есть к нам бесплатные чуваки заходят, и мы как -то по айдишкам видим, что повторяющиеся заходят. Значит, удержание есть, бесплатное удержание есть
Игорь А.: значит регулярные причины вернуться есть накопительный опыт есть посмотрите бесплатно же мы даем букви сожидает бесплатно пользоваться собой
Александр Бондаренко: если накопительную это есть и удержание есть значит как бы потенциал потому что я буду хотеть купить потом это тоже высокий
Александр Бондаренко: я тут плыву пока я не нему не вижу на кончах картинку вы тоже думаете об этом ok честность прогресса ну наверное нужна стратегия контента потом делаем производственную линию контента
Александр Бондаренко: он даже чувак который нам придем
Maxim Sagibgareev: все равно это все надо будет ему давать
Александр Бондаренко: ядро понимание там и ты говоришь
Maxim Sagibgareev: игорь то что 21 в неделю это максимум до минимум 7 неделю правильно Ну, это на начальном этапе всегда делается больше, чтобы зацепить тему какую -то понять. А потом уже достаточно одного
Maxim Sagibgareev: в день ролика, чтобы на теме понятной хайповать, условно говоря, то есть собирать максимальные охваты. Понял. Понял вас, смотрите. То есть, как бы здесь контент есть образно -маркетинговый,
Maxim Sagibgareev: который вы сейчас говорите, а есть который непосредственно внутри игры, как бы играбельный. играбельный то есть количество вузов например
Александр Бондаренко: и ячеек на каждый устам локация если по поэтому съесть цена есть есть какое -то решение там это дает дает в общем что -то вот
Maxim Sagibgareev: такое приходят тоже контент наполненность
Игорь А.: какими -то штуками которые полезны тебе как бы внутри сервиса бесплатно
Maxim Sagibgareev: пользоваться как родитель как подросток
Игорь А.: результат
Maxim Sagibgareev: оценить
Игорь А.: шансы он может быть платный также он может быть бесплатный
Maxim Sagibgareev: на каком -то бесплатном уровне мы тебя можем оценить
Игорь А.: там соответствует твоего направления вот как вот скринь делает все
Maxim Sagibgareev: ты его сделал тебя ну как бы
Игорь А.: удобный кабинет ты в нем
Maxim Sagibgareev: и задача вернуться ну то есть у тебя должна быть какая -то мне кажется бесплатно получается версия которая что -то тебе позволяет либо увидеть информационно либо там с нейроконсультантом
Maxim Sagibgareev: сделать мира крика карьерист или как он там профориентолог вот потом количество операций модерации обслуживание но это уже другое как выглядит остановка завершить проект сохранить доступ
Maxim Sagibgareev: и поддержку вы нести объемом 0 прошу прощения но если нейрокарьерист мне вдруг решит от нас уйти и построить карьеру другом месте значит херово работаем до уйдет как сам поступит вуз
Maxim Sagibgareev: да да да да да все мне на самом деле мы никого не держим если генеральный карьерист захочет пойти по другой мы ему поможем зачем пусть обращается к нам так себе пусть обращается и так
Maxim Sagibgareev: снизить объем обновлений пересмотреть инфраструктуру а ну вот то есть как мы хотим снизить получается совместную платную игру чтобы там ну и и завершению привести снизить объем обновления
Maxim Sagibgareev: кей бесплатно планировать прекращение сервиса и коммуникацию с игроками это завершение да ну нам не обязательно завершать у нас может быть какая -то гибридная смесь между тремя этими
Maxim Sagibgareev: штуками я думаю она так и должна быть бесплатную заходят потом могут купить что -то законченное какой -то продукт законченный и могут какой -то совместный продукт купить приступе о
Maxim Sagibgareev: чем сейчас все
Александр Бондаренко: говорили законченный продукт вот пожалуйста мои курсы или там вот у меня есть прикольные там тестирование совместный ну давайте со мной вместе а мне тут еще не просто со мной сеанса
Александр Бондаренко: еще есть
Maxim Sagibgareev: там еще мой коллегам этом вдвоем будем присутствовать это будет дороже стоит у вас сразу с двумя экспертами поговорю окей в общем здесь все обсудили то что есть успех игрока получили
Maxim Sagibgareev: обещанный опыт завершение возвращения социальная связь рекомендации это все разные результаты и как бы разные рестницы ok
Александр Бондаренко: успех проекта создан ли результат нужного
Maxim Sagibgareev: качества в доступных ресурсах
Александр Бондаренко: супер коммерческий творческий результат рассматривается отдельно согласно и устойчиво самой студии остаются ли деньги уходит ли нейро сотрудники или остаются компетенции какие тут права
Александр Бондаренко: собственность выполнять следующий проект успешная игра устойчивая компания и
Maxim Sagibgareev: сохраненный доступ
Александр Бондаренко: игроков не то же детстве хорошо саш открой там я документ скинул давайте мы на одной волне просто идет прям усваивается все хорошо или или нужен перерыв я думаю что лучше мы добьем
Александр Бондаренко: давай
Maxim Sagibgareev: открывай
Александр Бондаренко: я гинул короче контекст говорю какой во первых по картинкам пройдись открой картинки которые я скинул нормально я просто хочу зафиксировать что мы как раз это обсуждали и пришли к данному
Александр Бондаренко: файлу когда рассматривали какие продукты будем продавать на вебинаре возвращаю вот к тому и первому нашему заданию почему мы собрались вот и если здесь рассматривать вот как раз таки
Александр Бондаренко: эта модель тоже приводит к трем скажем так трем разным пакетом вот то есть мы тогда с тобой на основе этого можем потом подумать вот это то что хотел сказать вот этот файл макс сейчас
Александр Бондаренко: я еще кучу кидаю подожди тут раз уж у меня просили там собрать все я сейчас кидаю у меня есть книга как бы зарождение книги она написана нейронкой не говорю не ручаясь за качество но
Александр Бондаренко: про профессии кидаю еще с вам
Александр Бондаренко: надо будет ее я просто чтобы собрать потом мы еще я это сделаю ну пусть все будет у нас вместе так кидают в материалы правильно новая карта про глава 1 новая карта профессии как родителю
Александр Бондаренко: принимать решение без паники вечер на кухонном столе список вузов распечатка с проходным баллами телефон с открытым чатом родителей надо уже определяться говорит мама сейчас вам нужен
Александр Бондаренко: айти это надежно добавлять нормальный всем
Maxim Sagibgareev: нужен айти а
Александр Бондаренко: всем нужен да сейчас я уже найти это надежно добавляет папа выберите нормальную профессию они какие -то эксперименты пишет бабушка сын в это время пожимает плечами я не знаю в этой
Александр Бондаренко: короткой фразе вся тревога семьи почти каждый родитель такой не раз лоб просто пиздец. Вот вы знаете, у меня нейронка где -то уже такое выдавала. Это вот такая классика, если
Maxim Sagibgareev: честно. Я не знаю, я
Александр Бондаренко: прям...
Александр Бондаренко: Слушайте, мне кажется, она
Maxim Sagibgareev: в целом какие -то хранит базу ответов и при подобных запросах отвечает. Потому что, Макс, мы с тобой, когда пообщались, я вот этот файл закинул, говорю, что ты из этого видишь? Какой
Maxim Sagibgareev: продукт? И он мне собрал примерно такой же кабинет, как ты мне скидывал, чат от GPT. Вот, примерно такой же, я такое открываю, думаю, блин, ну походу реально он шаблоны себе запоминает,
Maxim Sagibgareev: как успешные, и на этот опыт начинает опираться, как релевантный. Ну, смотрите, парни, смотрите, вот первая глава, дойдите до конца, первой главы, до второй, там написано выводы главы,
Maxim Sagibgareev: написано, в эпоху искусственного интеллекта выигрывает не тот, кто угадывает правильную профессию, а тот, кто научится работать с меняющимся миром задач видеть себя проверять гипотезы
Maxim Sagibgareev: собирать факты делать выводы и двигаться дальше следующий главе разберем почему вопрос кем ты будешь часто ломает диалог семье и как заменить его вопросами которые реально помогают
Maxim Sagibgareev: подростку расти ну как бы тут тоже доработать но какой -то выводит прикольный потом дальше 2 глава осмотрим вывод главная задача показать что семейный диалог и формулировка вопросов
Maxim Sagibgareev: можно привести из тревожного разговора в рабочую систему действий когда есть короткий цикл проб явные критерии и уважения личности подростка выбор становится точнее тут как бы чистый
Maxim Sagibgareev: не расслаб но ядро зернышки здесь есть правды идем дальше глава 3 просто чисто проверка вывод показать что
Александр Бондаренко: перестройка рынка
Maxim Sagibgareev: труда и роль человека можно перевести
Александр Бондаренко: из этого разговора в рабочую систему действий когда есть короткий цикл упьянный по сути начал повторяться наверно да смотрите это еще бывшая нейронка плохая которая делала это моя бывшая
Александр Бондаренко: вот показать что наблюдение за устойчивым интересом
Maxim Sagibgareev: подростка можно перевести из обычного разговора в рабочую систему короче он тут все одно и то же делает там вроде была проблема с этой книгой мы сделаем реально книгу которую там можем
Maxim Sagibgareev: бесплатно можем на 200 за 200 рублей там отдавать это вообще будет разъем потому что книга этот гига доверия ну типа ну смотрите да мы сейчас к этому
Александр Бондаренко: придем я сейчас еще
Maxim Sagibgareev: одну штуку кину кинул
Александр Бондаренко: мне же исследовательский глюк есть который
Maxim Sagibgareev: вечный поток исследование идет и в общем я сейчас кидаю вам очень интересное улучшение улучшений ну типа того да книгу я увидел я это ну да это же хорошо это круто это пилотный не расслаб
Maxim Sagibgareev: который полный ну там он он даже самой нейронка которая делала мы тестировали здесь агентскую систему на open club и open club не сделали полную херь потому что я плохо настроил но
Maxim Sagibgareev: давайте запишем что книгу надо сделать по -любому
Александр Бондаренко: так
Maxim Sagibgareev: идем теперь смотрите открывайте не последний, который я скинул, а я скинул в all. спасибо за ксат на мпсс да это супер вот смотрите соберу проблематику main experts может кто -то прочитать
Maxim Sagibgareev: слух и велики а вот тут страх на протяжении жизни и потом да не приходи а соберем проблематику main experts по вашим прошлым беседам и исследованиям отдельно подростки и молодые взрослые
Maxim Sagibgareev: родители и трудности которые возникают между ними использую навыки персонал контекст и выбрали чтобы найти исходное обсуждение отчета 3 зафиксированной проблемы от моих выводов нашел
Maxim Sagibgareev: видимо это первое до нашел ранние разборы двух реальных клиентских семей базу семейной боли и материалы скринга main experts уже видна общая линия семье нужно связать понимание ребенка
Maxim Sagibgareev: выбор образования ежедневное действие и будущую самостоятельность проверяю будущее позднее исследование не помогут очень картину и дать обоснования я понял дачу делал нашел еще две
Maxim Sagibgareev: важные линии семейную матрицу с 90 под видами проблем и сентябрьские исследования образовательных и карьерных решений дошедшие до версии 14 существенная оговорка из самих документов
Maxim Sagibgareev: Большая матрица – это карта гипотез, а не тысячи интервью. Поэтому в сводке отдельно отмечу реальные клиентские случаи, результаты исследований и предположения для проверки. Картина
Maxim Sagibgareev: стала шире подростковой профориентации. В ваших материалах есть также переход студентов к работе, самостоятельность молодых взрослых, ожидания обеспеченных семей и отдельная взрослая
Maxim Sagibgareev: карьерная ветка. соберу их общую иерархию собрать сохранить почерпно подробный отчет с реестром найденных суждений документов для читаемой версии pdf очень интересно это
Maxim Sagibgareev: то что ты хочешь то да вот он прям про право сказал отделе от
Александр Бондаренко: своих каких -то выдумок
Maxim Sagibgareev: и суждений а возьми реально чего было ну да вот вот она вот она да я тебе сейчас все кидаю я быстро пока с вами общаюсь сейчас не так много файлов какие -то они прям здесь сырые но
Maxim Sagibgareev: какие -то нормальные то есть так сейчас но я понял что сырые не всегда получается переработать на самом деле да есть у меня время хватит фокусироваться сделано то есть как бы тут надо
Maxim Sagibgareev: просто сфокусироваться на этом какая -то html к карты родительского пути давайте я тоже скину что -то странная история но может быть она вот как раз я только что кинул там вторая версия
Maxim Sagibgareev: вот первую кидаю почему -то 4 то есть
Maxim Sagibgareev: первый заход это
Maxim Sagibgareev: в июле еще отдел 16 июля а июня июня потом я сделал семейно детская матрица более так
Maxim Sagibgareev: вроде бы 4 версия сейчас открываем упорная модель да да
Maxim Sagibgareev: семейно детская
Александр Бондаренко: матрица более ну как раз таки то что вы хотели
Maxim Sagibgareev: тут исправленным с третьей версии принципе уже выверенная более -менее надо проверить насколько тут не расслаб в целом ну это много чего записывал говорил думаю ты тоже увидишь что
Maxim Sagibgareev: -то здесь полезно тут есть устойчивое ядро по крайней мере и так далее так идем дальше теперь семья и будущее вот есть 19 20 сентября делал сейчас кину визуальный атлас такой прям не
Maxim Sagibgareev: знаю да вообще все обсудим потому что это реально важно ого ну прям красоте так кидаем тут прикольно не читал ребят честно не читал сделал не успел прочитать поэтому вы тут у нас всех
Maxim Sagibgareev: есть нейронки вот это у нас получается визуальный атлас сейчас кину отчет прям большой отчет то
Maxim Sagibgareev: есть контент у меня есть он создан что удалось установить всякие истории как читал данные там и так далее выводы которые можно опираться будущее включает желаемые результаты не только
Maxim Sagibgareev: опасения сша родители высоко ценят финансовую самостоятельность и интересную работу ребенка во французском опросе большинство участников двух молодых возрастных групп уверены в ближайшем
Maxim Sagibgareev: будущем
Александр Бондаренко: разные перспективы
Maxim Sagibgareev: это разные перспективы поэтому обоснован вывод о необходимости изучать и надежды и ограничения единая доля оптимистических семей не рассчитывается у короче тоже неплохо то есть тут
Maxim Sagibgareev: были разные опросники я хотел чтобы он в открытых источниках нашел данные про проблематики и про интересам подростков из и их родителей насчет взрослый насчет будущего и вот этот атлас
Maxim Sagibgareev: он тоже об этом теперь у меня есть исследование более развития я вроде бы и и кинул сейчас я посмотрю это она или не на да
Maxim Sagibgareev: вроде до образовательные карьерные решения да
Maxim Sagibgareev: это вроде бы а это сейчас секунду
Maxim Sagibgareev: что сентября тут что то сентября так
Maxim Sagibgareev: окей теперь то что я его попросил как раз таки то что он делал то что вы читали сейчас могу кинуть коротко его ответ он сопоставил все посмотрел и
Maxim Sagibgareev: сопоставил все документы и дал свой обзор вот кидаю это и
Maxim Sagibgareev: кину сейчас это в файле
Maxim Sagibgareev: сейчас
Maxim Sagibgareev: милин херова то что как -то он разбито сделал
Maxim Sagibgareev: попробую так так
Maxim Sagibgareev: будет плохо если я картинки сейчас кину по 1 то наверное они не сохранятся в одной стопке да давайте лучше зайду сейчас телегу и оттуда загружу чтобы потом не потеряться в этих фотографиях
Maxim Sagibgareev: в общем смотрите вот что он нашел по проблематике аудитории сегодня это прям сейчас пока мы говорили я быстро это дело чтобы вам дать сейчас
Maxim Sagibgareev: он еще одну сделает у меня более целостную по всем вообще пройдется интегральную историю сделать вот я загрузил пока ничего нет ну как бы не открываем сейчас пойдем и вот фотографии
Maxim Sagibgareev: которые пинсаре
Maxim Sagibgareev: он сейчас здесь
Maxim Sagibgareev: хочется исследовать у меня какие были мысли понять ну там в открытых источниках еще где -то посмотреть ну
Maxim Sagibgareev: учитывая там подростков учитывая их родителей какая вообще живет проблематика в открытом пространстве информационном я запускал эти
Maxim Sagibgareev: запускал не ромку чтобы она это делала и давала какие -то там интересные отчетики
Maxim Sagibgareev: ну
Maxim Sagibgareev: давайте я вас кинул и дико чул карьер который присет версия 1 26 сентября так чем и читаем сейчас мы посмотрим что
Maxim Sagibgareev: именно мы моделируем как как что стало понятнее давайте что собой управление образовательным и карьерными решениями во времени
Maxim Sagibgareev: поступление составляет один участок этой системы человек может прийти с отсутствием направления с уже выбранным направлением с трудностью исполнения, с семейным разногласием, после
Maxim Sagibgareev: неудачного опыта или после новой возможности. Поэтому единицей работы остается эпизод решения, то есть когда нам нужно помочь им принять решение какое -то.
Maxim Sagibgareev: Микроигра — это эпизод решения, а семейная или личная траектория связывает такие эпизоды между собой. Рабочая гипотеза о повторяемых задачах получила предметное наполнение. в публичных
Maxim Sagibgareev: рассказах встречаются
Александр Бондаренко: организации действий
Maxim Sagibgareev: проверка содержания программ согласование критериев уточнения интересов через опыт так но чистоту мы них не знаем сегмента не знаем и так далее практически вывод так что меняется модели
Maxim Sagibgareev: на этом и пропускаем какая проверка и где у границы так сбор извлечения ну это описательная история по великобритании по сша по россии по германии по австралии китая вот то есть просто
Maxim Sagibgareev: было изучение так какая задача остается после первичного выбора как как расходятся участники что меняется после опыта зачем проверять содержание программы какие альтернативы помощи
Maxim Sagibgareev: используются что известно о покупке и разрешаем то есть мы же как бы сервис оказываем хочется понять какие проблемы тут вот из разных источников все собрать ну и вот описывает сам само
Maxim Sagibgareev: исследование и объект наблюдения на странице 5 обубликованный материал они проверенная личность или жизнь семьи то есть мы просто смотрим на косвенные данные так мы гражданстве вот
Maxim Sagibgareev: в сообщении одного члена семьи слова другого остаются пересказом так в открытом корпусе недостаточной основы выделить именно высокодоходных семей которые богатые 7 ну ничего страшного
Maxim Sagibgareev: так покрытие перекоса смотрите что удалось рассмотреть великобритании важно выбор курс курса родителей
Александр Бондаренко: изменение программы заявка переход вуз потом
Вадим Х.: сша
Александр Бондаренко: обсуждение частных консультантов задач альтернатив германии ориентация
Maxim Sagibgareev: аузбилдинг не значит к практика официальная бесплатная помощь австралия студенческий опыт программы спор о выборе россия современный опрос подростков и описание услуги так китай семейные
Maxim Sagibgareev: различия в одной компании галко ok что там поискал что именно мы моделируем есть траектория изменения интерес не обновляет накопленные знания просто ректор его человек код есть какой
Maxim Sagibgareev: -то участник у него есть какой -то эпизод с разными задачами может возвращаться какие -то есть варианты
Maxim Sagibgareev: университета один из вариантов на движение предметы это варианты практика это варианты
Александр Бондаренко: тип образования варианты программы это варианты работа ли паузы это вариант и так условиях ну
Maxim Sagibgareev: да предпочтение существимость то есть я хочу это а у летать из россии не хочу например вот хочу в супер того вузы мира от топового вуза мира нет в россии то есть условие короче ограничения
Maxim Sagibgareev: какие -то основания всего этого помощь пересмотр окей возраст и повторяемость 13
Maxim Sagibgareev: 14 лет может стоять задача
Игорь А.: выбора предмета ну пробу это каких -то там не знаю на
Maxim Sagibgareev: какие
Александр Бондаренко: -то как они сессии как они называют секции секции вот на всякие секции ходишь какие -то занятия даешь на секции там спортивные кружки и вот эти всякие это и есть
Maxim Sagibgareev: проба 13 14
Александр Бондаренко: лет выбор предметов в 15 17 несколько одновременных развилок после начала учебы проверка уже ожиданий в 25 40 переход при обязательствах накопленном опыте
Maxim Sagibgareev: но уже куда переход на другую так окей идем дальше четвертое смотрите информации может хватать ориентироваться все еще трудно то есть вот такая гипотеза
Maxim Sagibgareev: то есть исследование 2025 года ну и не знаю какая здесь выборка на тоже посмотреть но все то ли процент участников оцениваю информацию как достаточную трудную труду для ориентирования
Maxim Sagibgareev: то есть одно дело дать информацию другую показать ее так чтобы было понятно то есть вот смотрите в конце написано это поддерживает разделение доступа к информации это одна задача а
Maxim Sagibgareev: вторая задача способность использовать ее в выборе то что помните нам говорил артем чтобы было удобно на юай на и уексе было понятно война юай как применить Вот,
Александр Бондаренко: это вот про это.
Maxim Sagibgareev: Желание покупать еще один информационный продукт, это, ну, другая история. Окей, дальше. Содержание программы – это один из критериев. Применимость требует проверки. Так, в обзоре ЮКОС.
Maxim Sagibgareev: ЮКОС – это система подачи заявок в ВУЗы в Великобритании. Встречащие проходит? Нет, чисто английское. Чисто английское, да. Чисто английское. И когда ты поступаешь на бакалавриат, ты
Maxim Sagibgareev: всегда через нее подаешь документы. вот они делали какое -то исследование по содержанию модулей и рейтингов одинаковых ролей так отмечены одинаковой долей смотрите содержание модулей
Maxim Sagibgareev: что внутри программы и рейтинг этих программ от типа статусы до одинаково оценивались по важности 30 процентов сказали нам важно что внутри программы и какой рейтингу программы а 51
Maxim Sagibgareev: процент кайли нам важно где находится сам вуз
Maxim Sagibgareev: расположение и
Maxim Sagibgareev: по их анализу нельзя утверждать что модули в целом важнее рейтинга ну
Maxim Sagibgareev: есть какая -то разница поступления как бы разнятся да ну в целом вот вам вот что дает как бы исследовательский процесс как раз то что ты хотел саш какую конкретно информацию в бесплатном
Maxim Sagibgareev: формате нам нужно дать то есть чтобы на какие вопросы они могли ответить так ривен публикует историю обновлений требований и модулей вместе это обосновывает проверку версии программы
Maxim Sagibgareev: но не доказывает рынок платного аудита ну
Maxim Sagibgareev: так по сути людям важно посмотреть детали программы даже вот на уровне того хотят ли они с нами сотрудничать или нет а какие то вы с европой тоже работаете до работы а какие порекомендуете
Maxim Sagibgareev: нам на горных инженеров я такой про себя думаю что за куда я знаю город вот но говорю хорошо а вы про фронтацию делали нет и потом когда задаю вопрос саму подростку от реально хочет
Maxim Sagibgareev: только горных инженеров он такой да не открыт к разным версиям у родителей одна картинка а согласованность картинки еще нету у ребенка другая у родителей есть твердость и жесткость
Maxim Sagibgareev: вот только надо туда а у подростка гибкость есть плюс нашей кодис провели наш тоже за это про видно что уже за это вот вот вот вот это мы и копали мой дед капал хочу чтобы ребенок тоже
Maxim Sagibgareev: копал да я не только по этим а вычел водой но выберу все другой ну да и рынок говорит ребята смотрите копать уже копать хорошо но индустрия проседает как бы там денег не так много но
Maxim Sagibgareev: сейчас уже будет побольше на работу что выросли цены но но суть в чем если робототехника там тоже инженеры нужны это растущий рынок если ты научишься ты на опережение пойдешь и будь
Maxim Sagibgareev: я бы другие зарплаты и другой другой инженер будешь то есть я вот об этом говорю то есть есть видение родители виднее ребенка знания их и наше знание как платформы по всей по всей экономике
Maxim Sagibgareev: мира но даже локально пусть будет не по всей там какими -то регионами мы знаем там европу знаем знаем то есть и к тому что он может сам это посмотреть эти данные ну что то что то может
Maxim Sagibgareev: посмотреть как бы какую -то вот я я хочу понять что для них важно за что они в конечном итоге готовы будут платить либо регулярно возвращаться. Вот на том слайде прям золотое правило.
Maxim Sagibgareev: Регулярное возвращение. То есть вот он... Зачем будет регулярно... Это важно.
Maxim Sagibgareev: Это важно. Так, хочу остановиться на секунду, дать слово Игорь. Продолжаем, все нормально. И Саш, тебе тоже.
Говорящий 7: Продолжаем, все нормально.
Maxim Sagibgareev: Запись идет. Как у них узнать... Как у них узнать, вот мое мнение, как у них узнать лучше всего, за что они будут готовы платить? Мое мнение, это вот сейчас мы нагоним,
Maxim Sagibgareev: трафика минимальная какая -то часть какая -то часть короче что -то у нас купит и самый кто вот больше всего понравилось продукт мы просто спросим мы скажем вот смотрите вам понравилось
Maxim Sagibgareev: мы можем сделать например и слабую консультацию но мы вам позадаем какие -то например вопросы продуктовой хотелось что не хватает огонь круто бро круто ваще огонь у меня знаешь какой
Maxim Sagibgareev: единственный момент вот смотри за хуя я делаю эту всю херь то есть вот сейчас отвечаю вам я знаю вы этот вопрос давно хотите задать ну я как бы предполагаю что знаю но мне кажется сейчас
Maxim Sagibgareev: я вижу вот то что сказал смотри какая тут прикольная тема они нам скажут какой -то список причин чего -то почему они что -то хотят купить вот они скажут там три причины один ты причины
Maxim Sagibgareev: другой вот я хочу купить туда да правильно же чем мы получим после того что ты скажешь ну мы с ними поговорим задел вопрос и мы поймем она ну смотри скорее всего нужно сопровождение
Maxim Sagibgareev: а этому там скорее всего нужно там шансы поступления короче какие -то они дадут объяснялки свои почему они готовы перейти вот
Maxim Sagibgareev: крутой есть у вас ну там крутой список репетиторов или дайте мне визуальные карточки в лицо хочу посмотреть каждый будет по -своему